Three,
two,
one,
boom.
And we're live.
Hello Godfather.
How are you,
sir?
Good to see you buddy.
You too.
Thank you for having me again.
My pleasure.
What's up?
What's up with you?
Well,
before we start for Easter,
I'm doing well.
People ask me,
how do you define wealth?
You define wealth when you're young.
Daughter,
before you step on the Joe Rogan
Platform,
writes this to you.
She wrote,
I love you.
That's very cute.
That's wealth.
Other billionaire?
Yeah.
It's a valuable.
Wouldn't say it's wealth.
I think not being accurate with your
words.
By the way.
I will probably keep this forever bore.
You should.
Yeah,
definitely don't put in your pocket.
What if you sweat on it?
Okay,
I'll leave it to you.
How's that?
So,
uh,
we were talking right before the podcast
started about what I was just talking
about in the previous podcast about
Patriot and what Patrion is done.
Two d platform Sargon of a cod in what?
I think we both agree was sloppy use of
language on his part,
but he was,
I don't believe he was saying something
racist.
He was using a racist word though it was
using it to describe someone who is
actually using it against white
nationalists against white supremacists
and and saying how ridiculous they were
being in that they were being exactly
what they describe and when they're
using racist terms to describe black
people,
but he did it using those terms and it
wasn't a good speech like what he said
and one of the things that I'd said on
the previous podcast is when you do
podcast,
you're not mapping out what you're going
to say.
You're free flowing.
Sometimes words come out clunky and I
think that was what what was going on in
the case with him in this particular
conversation that he had.
There wasn't even on his page and
patriot and decided to ban him and I
think for him that was something to the
tune of a $12,000
or more a month.
Yeah.
So quite a bit of his income.
You know,
a lot of us then suggested that people
move to subscribe star,
which was a another platform that came
out of nowhere and they've now been shut
down.
How'd they get shut down?
I don't know the details,
so I hope I'm not misspeaking,
but I think paypal and stripe decided
that somehow they're violating their
terms of their terms of service for
whatever reason and uh,
apparently any payouts that have gone
out are safe,
but you,
it won't happen through paypal or
through stripe,
so you have to find some alternate
platform,
I think pioneer or something,
uh,
so it's getting difficult to,
to even receive the generous donations
from people.
So a lot of people that are doing
podcasts and doing these youtube shows,
they operate
on donations,
which is a really fair way to do things
because you're.
If say if you have a subscription based
service and you're asking people like
save for Sirius satellite radio or
something like that,
you might not be happy with the content
and you might,
you might choose to cancel your
subscription,
but these people can get what they get
already for free.
Right?
They choose to donate because they think
it's valuable to them.
Which was really interesting.
I liked that,
that format,
that model,
because for the longest time people were
trying to figure out how could you make
money off the Internet?
Well,
the,
the idea was advertising revenue and Sam
Harris has a lengthly rant that's very
accurate about this that he puts on his
podcast may often.
It's like a seven minute rant explaining
why he doesn't use ads and why he
prefers to have people just donate what
they were like.
And he was one of the biggest patrion
people.
He was one of the biggest accounts on
Patriot.
He pulled his Patriot on two days ago.
Right.
And you know,
that was a huge statement because to him
that is incredibly valuable.
I'm really curious to know what Jack
Conte,
the founder of the have patriot,
what his ultimate trajectory is going to
be as someone who teaches psychology of
decision making was studies,
decision making who's housed in a
business school.
Uh,
um,
I think it would be a wonderful case
analysis down the road,
follow the Harvard will teach it of
whether he just doubles down,
which it seems like this is what they're
doing because they released a statement
that didn't seem to suggest that there
was any sort of possibility of
reflection on their part.
Do you have a sense of whether the
market will allow him to sort of realign
his thinking or do you think he's just
going to double down all the way to
hell?
I think he's going to weather the storm
if I'm going to be completely honest,
not what I would like.
What I would like is for them to support
free speech and for them to make a
differentiation between what is the
actual hate speech and what is a clunky
use of language,
which is what I think Sargon did,
right?
It was a clunky use of language and I
think Sargon is a very intelligent guy.
I've had him on the podcast,
I've talked to him.
He's a very bright and he had been on
the show several great point.
Yeah,
he's a very smart guy.
Um,
when he was on it,
just what is on someone else's show
doing that,
uh,
you know,
I felt like,
and this is one of the things I said in
the last podcast,
I feel like if people decide that what
he did was offensive to them to the
point where they decided to not renew
their subscriptions or not continue to
send him money through patriots,
that's probably the best use of that
format and the best way for them and the
market to decide.
That's really,
I think,
how it should be done.
Incidentally,
regarding the n word,
and I'm sure Jamie will now double check
what I'm saying as he always does a,
there was a dean
at some university,
I think out maybe in Seattle,
I could be wrong,
that at some point had suggested a,
someone had asked which book a student
that asks which book should I read or I
can't remember the exact story.
And I think the title of the book was
the n word.
And she had,
I think the dean was a,
was a woman,
like if I'm not mistaken,
uh,
had simply recommended that book.
But she said the word out loud said,
and she,
he or she,
I can't remember again,
the person's sex got into trouble.
So,
you know,
I wonder if we shouldn't just sort of
demystify this word in an if,
if,
if people weren't so.
I mean we have to now say the n word,
right?
We have to say the r word.
I got banned from twitter for 12 hours
because at one point I was interacting
with some schmuck who I called retarded,
the generate a whatever it was.
I can remember the exact combination of
consulting and I was banned for using
the r word.
So I mean,
where does this anime?
What,
how many more words do we have to remove
from the lexicon?
I mean,
don't give these words so much power.
Don't,
don't be so sensitive.
I mean,
I know we've talked about these kinds of
issues in the past,
but does it not seem too outrageous that
someone who recommends a book with the
title being the n word
gets into trouble and made some saying,
well,
as an even better one netflix.
There was an executive at Netflix that
was forced to resign due to my friend
Tom Seger is comedy special and my
friend Tom Segura has a bit in his act
about how there's certain words that are
just gone you can't use anymore,
and he says retard.
He's like,
that word.
You can't use that word anymore.
And he goes,
and it's not about using that word.
What?
He's basically,
he's not like,
he's not justifying the use of the word.
He just simply stating that this is a
word that you could no longer use.
So they get attacked a bunch of letter
writing campaign from mental health
organizations and you know,
people dealing with people that have
disabilities and are saying that you're,
you're being abelist and your being
discriminatory and all these different
things.
And they're basically trying to silence
him.
Even though if you look at the actual
bid itself,
he's not using it to describe a person.
He's just essentially it acknowledging
that the word exists.
So this guy who was an executive at
Netflix says in a meeting,
you can't use that word because that
word.
It's like saying nigger around black
people,
right.
Just says that you're going to get in
trouble now.
No,
I said it in the earlier show too.
I'm just saying when I read Sargon of
our cods thing,
I said it's preposterous to say the n
word and I've said the n word before and
in most cases I say it,
but he actually said the word and the
reason why he said the word,
the reason why I just said the word is
because he was trying to demonstrate
that this is an offensive thing,
like saying retard is just like saying
that he gets fired for that,
for simply making this comparison that
you know,
and we're talking about uncensored
standup comedy.
By the way,
this is a network that features that
were prominently on several different
comedy specials in multiple situations,
whether it's cat williams,
multiple uses of the word Dave
Chappelle.
I mean that word gets thrown about like
a beach ball at a fucking concert.
That word gets tossed around a lot,
but this guy saying it because he's
white.
He enough of your work here,
sir.
Speaking of comedy and sort of political
correctness with comedy,
uh,
and in my forthcoming book,
I have a section where I talk about
professors who got into Trello.
I mean we've all heard about the
comedians getting into trouble for
violating some politically correct
victim,
but professors,
many cases,
very,
very high profile professors getting in
trouble for incredibly innocuous jokes.
And actually I brought a list of names
because I thought I might not remember
them.
Can I mentioned a few,
a few of the cases.
So Lasar Greenfield,
who was the,
uh,
president elect of the American College
of surgeons and the editor and chief of
a journal called General Surgery News.
W had written an editorial a few years
ago where he was talking about the
antidepressant benefits of coming in
contact with sperm and other words at
it.
And this was based on a peer reviewed
scientific paper.
Actually,
two of the authors of that paper are
folks that I know quite well,
friends of mine,
and they had demonstrated that women who
have protected sex versus unprotected
sex and up scoring differently on these
depressive measures.
In other words,
there was some sort of protective
element to actually being exposed to
sperm and so in his editorial,
he made a joke.
It wasn't during Valentine's,
he said,
so now there is a gift that a man can
give a woman that's beyond flowers or
chocolates or something to that effect.
He had to step down from being president
of the American College of surgeons.
He had to step down from being an editor
in chief because a whole bunch of women
were very offended by that sperm joke.
Now,
the,
the authors of the paper and question
wrote a brilliant response response
where they said,
how,
how could he be treated in this way when
all he was doing is actually literally
reporting the data,
the findings from our peer reviewed
study.
So that's one example.
Another example is a certain,
uh,
I think it's third.
Tim Hunt,
who was a Nobel Prize winner in 2001.
I remember this one.
Yeah,
right.
Who,
who he basically,
he was a speaking fee in Korea at a,
you know,
women in science conference where he
very in a jocular way said,
you know,
it's a real problem when you have women
in your lab.
They fall in love with you,
you fall in love with them,
and so it's better to have segregated
labs.
His wife,
by the way,
is a staunch feminist who's a very
prominent scientist and she confirmed
that he's hardly,
you know,
a rabid sexist.
He went through all sorts of health.
Yeah,
I remember that.
And he was joking and he was joking.
And I.
In the book I discussed several other
other of these examples,
so,
so imagine you would think that a
unblemished exemplary career as a
scientist up to getting a Nobel prize
could potentially protect you.
But one comment that someone decides
can,
can unleashed a tsunami of outrage and
you're dead.
Well,
I think the problem is reacting to the
people that are reacting to the camera.
It's not the common itself,
it's the cowards that are running things
that give into that.
And the Netflix thing is particularly
disturbing because it was internal,
it was people that were working in this
department that apparently went and
protested and they just decided that his
use was egregious and he shouldn't be
able to say those sounds with his face.
See,
see I,
I get a lot of letters from people
asking me,
well,
you know,
I'm facing a similar situation.
What should I do?
A professors out?
And my answer is fight back hard.
So I've had a couple of these
situations.
I had a guy on twitter,
the guy,
the guy who many refer to as a retard
started,
started contacting my university,
trying to get me fired when,
when it wasn't working with his tagging
my university on twitter,
he actually contacted the HR department,
Human Resources Department at my
university.
This is a random person.
What's a troll?
You got in touch with a troll and you
gave him what he wanted attention.
And then he,
he started to run with it.
You basically gave him an opportunity to
score.
It's playing a video game.
Exactly.
But now here's what happened.
The university's hr person contacts me
after hours.
I mentioned this actually recently on
the Rubin report,
the,
the lady in question contacts me to say,
look,
here's a complaint that's been filed
against you now.
My first instinct was,
oh,
someone in my job as a professor at the
university has complained about me,
which I couldn't think who that would
be,
but I would think that that's where the,
the,
the template of their influence over me
would reside.
No,
they had actually taken seriously a
random person on twitter contacting them
and filing a complaint under the guise
of he's a student.
Well,
he's not my student,
right?
I mean,
if a student,
uh,
costs me in an alley to Mug me,
I can't fight back because Bruh,
he's a student or I'm allowed to,
to deck him.
Right?
So this is a guy that I'm just having
fun.
I mean,
I'm doing it
with a smile.
We're going back and forth the size that
he's willing to go as far as try to get
me fine now,
let's suppose that he had succeeded.
Let's suppose that I hadn't fought back
because basically what I did with the
university,
I said,
are you literally thinking that it is
reasonable for you to be monitoring what
I do on my twitter account and the
example I gave her as an analogy,
I said,
if if I see you coming out of a pharmacy
with your daughter and I feel that
you're speaking to her in a current
manner that I don't agree with as a
parent,
can I report you to the university?
And that pretty much ended the
conversation very quickly,
but the fact that they felt sufficiently
embolden to actually reach out to me to
address this complaint shows you how
chilling the environment is.
It is.
Right,
but let's play devil's advocate.
Sure.
If I was someone who was taking your
class or if I was someone who is very
sensitive or someone who has certain
ideals and morals and the professor
who's teaching the class that I take
called somebody a retard,
I would.
I mean just being honest and I love you.
They.
I would.
I would say,
why is this guy doing that?
Like that's a stupid thing to do,
like why are you engaging with these
people online and these,
these base insults like that distasteful
insults.
Fair enough.
And why engage with people like that.
And I mean literally the reason I do it
as once in a while my wife falls asleep.
I don't feel like working on my
scientific papers or my boat crash or
whatever.
I'm tired and I'm on twitter and I hated
your advice to try to not engage with
people.
Some idiots catches my eye.
Oh Gee,
I used the word idiot.
You're allowed to say idiot for some
strange reason.
Okay,
okay.
You just can't call them.
So someone,
someone or where it catches my attention
and I decided to spar with them.
You,
you,
you like to get into the octagon and do
an aspiring.
I go on twitter and I have fun with some
idiot.
Right?
But when I just enjoy it and usually we
both laugh it off and we move on.
It's just part of my personality,
right?
I'm a fun guy.
I could be deadly serious and very
academic and scientific and as you've
correctly pointed in the past,
I could not take myself seriously.
It'd be just one of the guys,
so this is a manifestation of that now
that this person felt sufficiently in
bolden and his indignation that he would
try to fire me.
That's where you should be focusing on
sort of.
I don't think that's real.
I don't think he really felt so
emboldened.
I think what it was is he recognized
that there is a climate today where a
person like yourself,
who is a professor who uses a certain
word that is deemed to be offensive by
society,
that he can call you on that word and
get you caught.
You got caught up in a net of your own
doing,
sir.
Well,
I'm,
I'm still here smiling and looking fan,
so that's okay.
Do you do look tan?
Do you regret using that word at more
than anything I regret that ever get
sucked
into these battles?
That's it as much because again,
it's a slippery slope today.
It's retard tomorrow.
It's more on the next day.
It's schmuck.
Yeah.
Well,
that is true in terms of like were
people don't understand calling someone
a retard,
like say if you're a 30 year old person
today or 25 year old person,
let's try 25.
You realize that that is a forbidden
taboo when you and I were 25,
that word was nothing,
right?
That word you would to get called it by
your teacher.
I mean it's true.
That was new and it was known to be
someone who was retarding your growth or
retarding the class or saying things
that were retarding development of ideas
and,
and logic moving forward that you're,
you're,
you're a roadblock.
You're a pile of rocks in the road,
right?
You fucking retard.
Like that's how people talked about it.
Like that's how they said it,
but then it's become a new word that's
victim to this war on words because
you're not saying you have down
syndrome,
right.
What you're saying is you're a dumb
person,
you know,
and that terminology,
like especially the word retarded,
it is not even used medically.
Right?
So it's not a word and the to say that
there's no nuance and this word cannot
be used again about a really stupid
fucking person.
Right?
You know,
I,
as you know,
you probably know because I've sent you
some clips of my infant of soccer
skills.
Uh,
I used to be a very serious soccer
player.
Now if you,
you,
you know this as someone who follows the
MMA,
there's a lot of trash talking,
right?
So the amount of nine this time nominate
professor and so on.
But the amount of trash talking that I
both dished out and was the recipient of
actually allowed me to be a better
person today.
It's,
it's a form of antifragility,
right?
I mean by.
Yes.
So,
so when you create a sanitized
environment,
you're creating a fragile system.
You're creating fragile human beings.
So if,
if the,
if the worst stain in my 54 years on
earth is that I use the word retard on
this person.
I'm doing pretty well.
Well,
I'm sure it's not the worst day,
but uh,
yeah.
It's not that it's not that big a deal.
The only reason why it's a big deal is
because the climate,
right.
You know what you're saying is this is a
stupid person.
You're.
You're not accusing him of having a.
you're not mocking a,
a mental disease or disorder genetic
disorder.
It's not what you're saying and
everybody knows that,
but they're just decided that this is a
new word that is now taboo.
A new sound you can't make with your
face.
Yeah.
I want to move onto other chore.
So first I wanted to say that I was very
excited last year.
It's completely different.
This is a very hard segue with last
year,
one of my former professors at Cornell
won the Nobel Prize in economics.
That's pretty powerful.
First semester
at Cornell,
I took his course.
His name is Richard Thaler.
Maybe you should look into inviting them
here.
Uh,
I'll add an ofi he does a lot of these
podcasts,
but,
uh,
he should do your podcast.
And he won the Nobel prize for really
the,
the area that I started off in before I
developed all the evolutionary stuff
that I'm most known for.
I came out of a tradition called
behavioral decision theory.
Is that,
does that ring a bell at all?
Have you?
Do you know that is at all?
I'm really not totally.
No.
So classical economists have this,
uh,
if you like stylized homo economic,
this,
this vision of how someone who is
rational ought to behave and they are
these axioms of rational choice.
So for example,
if I prefer car a,
car B,
and I prefer carby to Carsey,
I must prefer car,
a third car.
See,
that's a,
that's called the transitivity action.
Someone who doesn't abide by this is
behaving irrationally.
If I tell you,
what do you think of this hamburger that
has 90 percent fat free,
it's the same thing as telling you that
this hamburger has 10 percent fat.
Those are two isomorphic statements.
It shouldn't alter your preference.
Yet we see repeatedly that people don't
behave in the manners prescribed by
classical economic theory,
by,
by homework analogous.
So Dick Thaler is the gentleman who
demonstrated how many of these axioms of
rational choice are violated in
behavioral finance.
And for that,
he won the Nobel Prize in economics and
he came after the ones who originally
wanted in 2002 Daniel Conaman.
You probably know his book thinking fast
and slow is I ring the bell.
Yes.
Right.
So Daniel Conaman and his collaborator,
Amos Tversky were the pioneers of that
field.
And that's really the tradition that I
came out of.
My doctoral supervisor was part of that
gang of guys who spent their careers
demonstrating that classical economists
are wrong.
In my case,
I became frustrated with that whole
paradigm because it became clear that
yes,
economists have it wrong.
How many more demonstrations can we show
that they are wrong?
I was much more interested in knowing
why the brain is structured the way that
it is enhanced.
That's how I got into evolutionary
theory,
but I just thought that I would give
them a shout out since he was a former
professor of mine.
That's pretty awesome.
I'm just happy there's people out there
trying to figure these things out so I
can read what they say and repeat it.
I know what I'm talking about.
Um,
I want to go back to target things being
fragile and antifragile.
I mean,
I think that's a really important point.
Develop and I don't mean develop thick
skin,
like become accustomed to racism or
sexism or homophobia or rudeness.
It's just,
I'm not saying that we should just
tolerate those things and we shouldn't
seek to improve our culture.
We definitely should.
But as a human being,
this celebration of all things,
triggering this,
getting upset at every single thing
that comes your way and making it out to
be some massive complication.
I think it's a direct result of how easy
society is and how simple our lives are.
Complicated in intellectual ways,
complicated in emotional ways,
complicated in psychological ways.
Because I think a lot of the way people
live their life is very unnatural but
simple in terms of not worrying about
predators,
not worrying about real violence,
not worrying about real strive,
never worrying about food.
I mean,
it's very rare that people in this
culture,
in this day and age are starving.
You know,
it's a huge problem for most of human
civilization.
Most of human civilization people had a
struggle to find food.
Now,
for the most part,
it's very rare and I think all of these
things have led us to seek enemies where
there are none and to go out and find
these problems that really are not that
big and make them out to be huge.
Right?
Because they're fragile and you know
this.
The idea that let's.
One of the reasons why I like that
expression snowflake,
like some,
some people get really upset if you
throw that word.
So the idea is that every snowflake is
unique and special,
right?
Right.
That's the idea.
And that you,
you are unique and special.
Maybe.
Maybe you're just lazy.
That's true too.
You know this.
This is our word for word and say that
either
I could link what I just mentioned about
classical economists to the social
justice warrior ethos.
So classical economists viewed the human
condition through very cold
calculational calculus.
You certainly like humans are these,
they,
they instantiate these algorithms
without any emotions,
right?
If I prefer to be up for paccar beater
car seat,
I much prefer a two car seats.
All axioms of rational choice.
There are no emotions in these models.
At the other end of that continuum lies
the social justice warrior because all
of life is through only the triggering
of the emotional system.
There is no engagement with your
cognitive resources.
It's all about outrage,
anger,
frustration,
and so in a sense they're antithetical
to each other.
The classical economists and his world
view,
there are no emotions.
The social justice warrior in his
worldview,
there is no cognition.
Of course,
the the right way to be is somewhere in
the middle.
The right way to be is to know when to
engage your cognition and went to engage
your emotions.
Yeah.
Isn't that the issue,
right?
Is that there's always the middle and
that things are rarely black and white
or one and zero often very complicated.
Well
bottle.
Going back to aristotle had argued about
sort of what we now with color,
I would call the inverted u shape.
So for example,
if most things,
the middle is the right place to be.
All things in moderation,
right?
If you have too little of something,
it's not good.
If you have too much of something,
Somewhere in the middle is where the
right virtuous and aristotle had thought
of that several thousand years ago.
I'll give you a specific example.
I'm not sure if I've mentioned that
before.
In this podcast.
Perfectionism right follows an inverted
u shape.
If you have too little audit,
you're not sufficiently detailed
oriented.
Your work suffers.
If you have too much of it,
which I'm happy not happy on.
This police report is me.
Then it could be stunting because I
checked my work 73,000
times before I sent it off because God
forbid I might have a comma wrong that.
So there is some happy medium of proof
on the perfectionism scale where we
should all strive to be.
Well,
Aristotle said that for most traits,
that's where the optimal is.
That's where the inflection point is.
That makes sense.
I mean,
I'm not one to argue against aristotle.
I thought you were gonna say you're not
one to argue against me.
I'm not one to argue against either one
of you.
I,
I just think most issues that people are
arguing for or against one of the real
problems is that they are married to
their initial point.
Yeah.
And they argue that looking for a
victory,
they're trying to move a ball across the
line and they do it by any means
necessary,
including by mislabeling people,
by mischaracterizing your positions on
things and categorizing you in some
really easy to dismiss place like you
are all right or you're,
you know,
you're a fringe right person or I mean,
how many people have been called a Nazi
over the last couple of years you've
been called the Nazi.
So when I was supposed to speak,
and August 2017,
uh,
at a event titled The stifling of Free
Speech on university campuses,
it was on a university campus.
It was shut down.
The irony was hilarious.
It was with myself,
Jordan Peterson,
uh,
another clinical psychologist or an MFA
and faith,
Goldie,
a journalist.
Uh,
anyways,
uh,
and then we held the event about three
months later,
but the people who shut us down had put
out a facebook page where they said,
we don't want these white supremacist
Nazis and Toronto.
This is to a Jewish person who escaped
persecution in Lebanon.
So yeah,
it's,
it's insane.
It's cute.
It is.
I mean,
they can't,
they can't be honest.
I mean this is not,
they don't honestly believe what they're
saying,
but they don't care because they're just
trying to move that ball.
Right?
And the fact that that's tolerated in
that not just tolerated,
but it actually influenced your speech
and you guys weren't allowed to put on
that event being shame.
Shame on the university for giving in
shame on them,
for not putting their foot down.
Shame on them for not examining who you
are,
who Jordan is,
who one of those people are,
and realizing,
no,
you're lying you,
you are a problem.
You calling these people white
supremacists and Nazis your a problem
and you're a liar and you're defaming
these per.
This is defamation.
This is your,
your light bulb.
This is terrible.
What you're doing is something that we
should shun,
but I think it speaks to what you said
earlier when you said it's all about
winning,
getting the ball across a.
that's a.
that's another thing that I talk about
in the book is the difference between
the ontological ethics and
consequentialist ethics.
The anthological ethics is where you
have moral absolute.
It is always wrong to lie.
That will be at the into logical
statement.
A consequentialist bent would be.
Well,
it depends on what the consequences of
the liat is,
if,
if it were to spare someone's feelings
than it might've been okay to lie.
Right,
and so I argue that a lot.
The problem with a lot of these enemies
of reason is that they have a
consequentialist relationship with
truth,
right?
It doesn't matter if you violate truth,
if there is some greater goal that you
are pursuing.
Whereas I come from a deontological
perspective when it comes to truth.
Truth is truth.
No matter who,
whose feelings it hurts,
and so I truly think certainly as a
scientist,
you truly have to have a the
anthological relationship with truth.
This is precisely why when a lot of
people ask me,
do you think that there is for a bit,
and I think we even mentioned that last
time I was on your show 16 months ago.
Uh,
is there any forbidden knowledge that
you shouldn't do as a scientist?
And my answer is always an unequivocal
no.
As long as you are a honest,
adherent to the scientific method,
you should be allowed to traverse any
intellectual landscapes.
Intellectual
landscapes can be problematic when they
deal with things that are very
uncomfortable for people.
A big one is Iq,
right?
That's a giant one and that one has
triggered so many accusations of racism
and
whether it was good.
There was a gentleman,
I just covered him on my,
on my youtube channel.
I don't know who he is.
His name is.
I think noah.
Carl.
He's a young,
I think postdoc at Cambridge University,
who from all I know is a very reasonable
gentleman who had been invited to speak
at a conference on intelligence.
And because of that,
a bunch of folks decided to put together
an open letter arguing that Cambridge
University should not hire this guy.
And so on.
This has now become the standard way by
which the baits are our resolve.
You signed these open letters,
so for,
had another guy on and you should
definitely check this guy out.
His name is Alice stromeyer.
Uh,
he is a,
do you know this case?
No.
He's a physicist at the University of
Pisa who was also a,
who was a research scientist at cern,
the,
the nuclear research center in Geneva.
He was invited to speak at a gender and
theoretical physics conference.
Everything is about identity politics.
And of course the narrative was going to
be,
you know,
women are discriminated against in
physics and you know,
we need to help them improve their lot
and physics and so on.
So he got up and he presented
bibliometric data.
So let me just,
for your viewers,
explain what that is.
Maybe we'll metric data is,
is a data that quantifies science.
So for example,
if I want to know which disciplines
sites,
which other discipline,
I will look at citation patterns across
disciplines.
Does economics oversight physics,
physics oversights a economics,
right?
So bibliometric data is a way to
parametrized science and so what he did
is he looked at for a given job in
physics,
if a woman gets a job versus if a man
gets a job,
how many citations did they have?
Citations.
Basically.
How many other people have cited your
work when you published it?
So you and I might have,
I have published 50 papers each,
but you've been cited 10,000
times.
I've been cited 2000 times.
Therefore your work is more influential
even though we've both published the
same amount of papers and he,
he showed through very objective data
that for a given position,
women were getting the jobs at much
lower citations while that was construed
as terribly offensive,
terribly sexist Nazi like and so over
1600 scientists using the the
Appalachian particles for justice.
I'm not making this up.
What you can go particles for just
young.
Jamie can check it out.
Yeah.
And you can,
you can read their letter and it
includes,
I think one or two of your former guests
who have become a very antiphonal auntie
fan,
not Antifa,
uh,
because to me they're sounding like
intellectual cowards and Fools.
Who were these people?
Uh,
I think one of them is Sean Carroll.
you know,
that is,
I think he's been on several times.
Yeah.
So he's on that list and I don't know,
I don't want to misspeak,
but I think maybe Neil degrasse Tyson is
on it,
but maybe not.
So that one,
that one,
I'll,
I'll hold off on that one.
But definitely Sean Carroll is on it
because I've even tagged him and I said,
hey,
come on my show.
That's discuss it.
So the letter was basically it starts
off and it says we will not tolerate
that.
Someone within our community,
I'm,
I'm paraphrasing,
will question the humanity of anyone
based on their race,
their gender,
their gender orientation.
He did no such thing.
All he did was report bibliometric data
to either support the contention that
women in physics were being
discriminated against or not.
That
should not yield a an open letter that
chastises him and the way that they did,
not the only thing that he did
incorrectly and my view,
and he's admitted to it.
He came on my show recently at one point
during the presentation,
he showed his bibliometric profile
versus to other women that had gotten a
job over him,
so he personalized it and and and doing
that.
Some people thought that that was
inappropriate and that's fair.
Maybe it's not a nice thing to do to
present your cv versus someone else and
a public conference.
Maybe we can discuss that,
but the idea that we can't use
bibliometric objective scientific data
to either prove or disprove a narrative
is insane and yet 1600 people decided to
sign that letter.
That does seem ridiculous,
especially when it's an accusatory
narrative.
You're accusing people of sexual
discrimination and then the,
the scientific data shows otherwise
exactly what they're looking for,
equality of outcome,
right?
They're looking for an equal amount of
female physicists and solid that that's
you just you're not going to get an
equal amount of people interested in it,
so then you,
you really have to show is you have to
determine that there's been something
that's holding those people back from
achieving that goal because if some sort
of a concerted effort to keep women out
of that field,
that's what should be demonstrated and
when you demonstrate that,
I think here's the,
here's the glass half full version of
that.
You're looking at that big blue biblio
metric data.
What that shows is that people are
encouraging women to get into this
because it's the opposite.
That instead of them being held back,
they're actually,
they're,
they're looking to even out the playing
field and help these women along.
The problem with that is then it makes
it look like the women aren't as capable
as the medics that were not as effective
as the men with their work and you know
that's bad for everybody.
That's bad for women and for men.
It's bad for science because it makes it
look like you're not being objective,
which is what all we want.
Every everyone who's not a scientist
like myself,
what I want more than anything is to
know that you're.
If you're a scientist,
I want to know that what you're telling
me is a fact.
What I don't want is your own political
spin on that fact because you don't want
to be criticized at work by radical
feminists or radical leftist or any
people that might in some way
potentially misconstrue your actions and
your thoughts as being sexist or what,
or fill in the blank,
homophobic,
transphobic,
whatever,
whatever the fuck it is that you're
scared of.
I don't want to hear that.
What I want to hear is that you're
looking at reality.
There are brilliant women out there
that's brilliant men out there and a lot
of those brilliant women choose not to
do the same fields is brilliant men and
as long as no one's holding them back,
that shouldn't be a problem.
The problem is got to be in someone
being held back,
someone discriminating,
someone trying to keep you out and you
you're going to have to demonstrate
that,
and I'm sure
that exists.
I'm sure that exists.
I'm sure there's women out there that
are hearing this right now that have
experienced all sorts of discrimination,
sexual discrimination,
sexual harassment,
and they have their own personal
stories.
This is true,
but that is not necessarily why the data
reflects that.
There's more men that are successful
with this.
It could seriously,
this is what people are really
uncomfortable with.
Seriously represented.
There's differences in the sexist and I
know that's so hard to.
Well,
this is so hard from the first time I
think that I came on your show when I
probably first discussed my evolutionary
psychology research.
I mean,
it's a fundamental tenant of
evolutionary theory that there are
sexual dimorphism.
When I appeared in front of the Canadian
Senate,
I had to sit there and lecture these
senators that there is such a thing as
male or female,
but meanwhile,
while many of them scoffed and laughed
and tried to mock me,
uh,
it turns out a few days ago,
there's now an elementary school.
You're teaching young kids that boys to
menstruate.
So literally every satirical,
every s,
I always joke,
I always say that I have prophetic
satire because every time I try to look
for something that is so outlandish that
it can enter into my satire,
two months,
three months,
eight months later,
it proves to be true.
So for example,
at one point I argued that I wanted to
compete in the octogenarian under 120
pound category in the judo cause you
identify first because I that the files
add 20 pounds.
But also I'm trans gravity.
I set my weight at whatever my weight is
there therefore,
and then because I can change my
identity on a daily basis because
Harvard University thought is that I'm
later going to fight in the under 18
year old category.
Hold on.
Harvard allows you to change it on a
daily basis.
Harvard University came out that's
actually discussed this in my Canadian
Senate testimony.
Harvard University's Lgbtq a a plus a
plus stars infinite to the Hashtag
prime.
Exactly.
They came out with a pamphlet that said,
not only can we change our heart,
our gender identity,
but it can fluctuate on a daily basis.
Right.
So I could be he she or Monday,
Tuesday,
Wednesday.
And so I took this idea and I said,
well,
I identify as an 80 year old under 120
pound Monday,
but then I'm going to fight in the judo
competition.
I use Judah because my brother was an
Olympian in judo as I think we might
have this discussed.
I'm going to fight and the under eight
category on Tuesday because I self
identify on Tuesday as being a child now
it sounds satirical and insane.
A Dutch gentlemen who's 69 years old,
did you know the ages and he just.
He decided that he identifies with
someone 20 years younger and he wants to
use it on dating apps and changes,
and then that would change his pension
thing.
Well,
one,
it was so,
so then.
Then I introduced a new term and then
that proved to be prophetically
satirical.
I coined a new condition called
transgenderism by proxy,
so,
so if,
if,
if you're watching now,
enjoy this.
If Joe and God have sex,
if I self identify you as a woman,
then I'm engaging in heterosexual sex.
So it's not about me self identify me.
Yeah,
I can change my identity exactly on your
own interpretations of.
Exactly.
So it's not,
it's not that my self identity changes
into a woman that the guy that I'm
having sex with,
I self identify as a female.
Well,
a few weeks,
maybe not even.
A few weeks later,
some trans activists on twitter came out
and said,
ew,
disgusting.
Transphobes.
Just because you have a excuse the term
a dick in your mouth doesn't mean that
that's a dick.
If it's a woman and I called this trans,
uh,
cunnilingus volume,
it doesn't mean it's a dick.
If that person that identifies as a
woman,
so just because you have a dick in your
mouth,
it doesn't mean it's a deck because
that's a woman.
You are giving sex to a woman.
Do you know?
Yeah.
There was a nine inch penis in your.
In your thing,
but it's a vagina.
Yale put.
They put tampons in the men's room.
Yes sir.
Of course.
I said that not only women.
Of course I.
that's true.
That's my.
That's my daily life.
That's called Tuesday for me,
man.
I have a hard time getting that out
because of my women aren't the only ones
who menstruate.
What?
Yes they are.
Yes,
they are.
God dammit.
What?
Boys can have periods to children to be
taught the latest victory for trend.
There you go.
I love how they say that.
The latest victory,
right?
Latest victory for who wrote that story?
Who wrote that?
Vox.
Who?
Halena.
Hey Halena.
Fuck off.
That's not a victory.
That's nonsense.
That is God damn nonsense,
but can I tell you what's not victory?
That's crazy.
Kids.
Kids don't know if you want to tell kids
that sometimes people are born in the
wrong bodies.
That seems to be true.
There seems to be real evidence to that
in terms of the way the brain works.
Sure.
I mean you,
if you want to call it the problem is
distinguishing it from normalcy in a way
that makes it look inferior.
Right?
Right.
Isn't that the real problem?
So if someone has this condition,
they shouldn't feel inferior and you
shouldn't be bigoted towards them and
they shouldn't live in a being exposed
to any of discrimination,
but we shouldn't change our
understanding of reality to celebrate
your unique personhood.
Exactly.
Incidentally,
one of the things I talk about in the
book,
all of these idea pathogens,
I argue some of them come from really
noble places,
high strung,
so as well.
Yeah.
So let's cover a few of these.
So,
for example,
the empty slate premise,
Tabula Rasa,
we're with empty minds,
is a profoundly idiotic position,
but it really stems from the noble
hopeful position that if we're all born
with equal potentiality,
we could all reach the same end
trajectory.
If only the environment were conducive
for us being top athletes,
top scientists stopped mathematicians,
then we would have reached it.
There is nothing inherently at the
start,
at t equals zero that differentiates of
now,
that's insanely stupid and wrong.
But it is a hopeful message.
Now,
extend this to other contexts,
right?
Uh,
it shouldn't be that you're defined by
your biological sex.
You could change it in any way you want.
That sounds very liberating,
right?
So I think a lot of these idea
pathogens,
what I call these,
these parasitic ideas really come from a
notion of trying to liberate people from
otherwise they're the shackles of
reality.
So it's insane.
It's a form of,
of delusional thinking,
but that is rooted in its genesis,
comes from a good place.
I,
I couldn't agree with that more and
gender dysphoria used to be considered a
used to be considered a mental disorder.
Right,
but isn't it right?
Well,
listen,
but what is it?
Okay,
but let's be honest,
if it's not,
if it's,
is it a physical disorder?
What is it?
I'll put it in a very charitable,
politically correct way.
It's certainly not part of the default
value of human expressions.
Do you see what I'm saying?
Male and female is the default values.
We are a sexually dimorphic species now
for all sorts of reasons until genetic
developmental reasons.
When the brain is getting typed in
Utero,
things can happen that altered those
default values.
Now you come out with gender dysphoria.
You shouldn't be discriminated against.
You should be treated with complete
respect.
You should be free of bigotry.
That doesn't mean that there is a
spectrum of possibilities of which that
one is one of the default values.
It's simply isn't it's wrong to argue
that,
but in the same way that feminists like
to argue that there are no innate sex
differences because that they think
would help alter the sexist status quo.
This is what's happening with Trans
Activism.
That's why they are consequentialist
when it comes to truth,
screw truth,
screw reality,
screw biological common sense in the
pursuit of freeing the world of bigotry.
You should be able to free the world of
political bigotry without constantly
attacking truth.
Well,
and here's the other question.
If it is not,
this is what I was getting at.
It is,
if it's not a mental disorder,
what is.
Is it a physical disorder?
Is it a disorder at all,
and if it's not a disorder,
why must it be treated medically?
Why must it be gender reassignment
surgery?
Why must there be exogenous hormones
introduced into the body?
Why is all that happening?
Rhetorical question or are you asking me
to just
walk up to them?
I mean,
it's kind of rhetorical.
There's no one here,
but if it's not a disorder than why are
these gender reassignment physicians
here?
If you,
if you don't have to have a sex change
to be a woman.
If you're a woman with a big Dick and
broad shoulders and a big hairy chest,
but you're a woman,
right?
Well,
what is the need for the doctor then if
you're already a woman,
if we decided that you're a woman,
so you just want to change your
appearance to outwardly match how you
feel.
Well that seems a disorder.
I wonder.
I'm not sure,
so I don't want to misspeak,
but I wonder if.
I think in the DSM five,
gender dysphoria is listed as a
condition.
Is that,
is that correct?
It is
it as a condition,
but it's not accepted by that in terms
of public perception and certainly in
terms of trans activists or lbgt
activists or anybody who talks about
these things in a progressive way,
that is a taboo.
Like the actual medical nomenclature
that's used to describe those conditions
is taboo.
Well,
there's,
I don't know if you heard about this
case.
There was a physician research
scientists at Brown University who
published a paper,
very serious data scientific data.
I think her name is Lisa.
Simple or liberal.
I can't remember her name.
Uh,
it was published I think in a plus one,
you know,
very serious scientific journal where
she looked at the social contagion.
You don't have a sort of transgenderism.
How,
if you know,
there definitely seems to beat well.
Well,
literally that is social contagion
effect.
Now that paper was published,
Brown had advertised,
it was published in a Peer Review
Journal while the Trans activist game
after that paper and Brown decided to at
least pull it off of it's sort of
promotional plan.
Uh,
I reached out actually to,
I think her name is Lisa,
to get her on the show,
but as you might imagine,
she was a bit tested.
Yeah.
She's probably shell shocked.
She's shellshocked and so I'm not sure
if she'll come,
but again,
here's a serious person who probably
isn't as liberal.
She's a,
she's a physician who deals with these
issues,
who was simply talking about the fact
that there's definitely a social
contagion effect that is taking place.
She's the Nazi.
Yeah.
There's people just
really,
really crazy when it comes to gender.
That seems to be the battle ground,
the battle ground between logic and
science.
It rests in gender and I have this
conversation with a friend of mine about
the gender pay gap and he was arguing it
as if it was a thing where there was a
man and a woman working right next to
each other doing the same job and the
woman was making seventy eight cents.
The man is making a dollar and he's a
smart guy and I had to explain to him,
I said,
this is not the case.
I go there.
They're doing different jobs.
They're working different hours.
I go,
you're,
you're spitting out.
Propaganda is
if it's true,
and he was reluctant to believe me.
He was like,
are you serious?
He any leary said this.
He goes,
I'm going to be very upset if I find out
that you're,
you're,
you're lying to me.
I go that I'm lying to you.
I go,
this is adorable.
You're,
you're going to be.
You don't even know what the fuck you're
talking about and you're going to be
upset if you find out that online,
I'm going to be upset if you don't have
fucking apologized to me when I show you
this.
So that,
so I know he did not.
I sent him the information,
I sent him many articles on it and I
sent him many critiques of the way.
Even the president of United States was
discussing this because they're doing it
in a very politically correct way that
is actually disingenuous.
I showed him the actual raw data that
shows that men work an average of.
I forget what the percentage is,
more hours that they are more likely to
die on the job.
They pick more risky jobs.
It's a totally different thing.
This is not discounting actual sexual
discrimination at work,
which I'm sure exists,
but this is not when you're looking at
the raw data,
which is what they're trying to say,
the seventy eight cents to a dollar.
They're saying this is just systemic
sexism across the board.
There's no other explanation for it.
So I showed him know there is other
explanations form.
It's different jobs.
It's working different hours.
It's.
There's probably a bunch of factors,
testosterone making you more aggressive,
making you more risk of or more a risk
taker.
Risk taking.
There's all sorts of different factors.
His response was sometimes the
perception of something is as important
as the fact I'm like you motherfucker,
I'm going to come to your house and
smack you in the face in front of your
woman.
You know,
but it's interesting that you say this
because what you are trying to do there
is use information.
Hopefully it's tsunami of information to
get them to move away from is anchored
position,
which is something that I discussed in
great detail in my book and I think I've
come to a similar realization to you
regrettably,
and that that is that oftentimes all the
information,
the world is not going to help.
It's not going to help.
He didn't want to lose.
He didn't want to lose and it really is.
You're putting your hands in your lap.
What he was trying to find a way to say
by him saying that perception is
sometimes more important than the actual
facts.
I'm just trying to say that he was
trying to say that women are
discriminated against because these
facts are paraded around in a way that
make women feel bad and because women
feel bad that they're making seventy
eight cents to the man's dollar.
That is just as important as the actual
reality of how much they make.
Am I?
God dammit.
This is.
You just spun a Web.
You spun a bullshit web and your.
Your legs are all trapped up in it.
You can't go anywhere now.
Well,
it speaks to another thing that I
discussed in the book.
So are you familiar with poppers,
falsification,
principal?
No.
So Karl popper was a philosopher of
science.
As a general rule,
I hate to read most philosophers because
they engage in a lot of highfalutin
bullshit that really doesn't get us
anywhere,
but philosophers of science actually
quite helpful and that they really help
us understand the epistemology of how to
learn about knowledge,
create knowledge,
tests,
knowledge,
and so Karl
popper argued that if you really want to
test a theory,
you have to be able to falsify the
theory that which cannot be falsified
cannot be considered a scientific
theory.
Right?
If the observation is this way,
it supports the theory of the
observation is this way at falsifies a
theory.
So for example,
fate is not a scientific theory,
right?
Because if I step out of my house today
and the truck hits me,
it was my faith.
If I step out of my house and the truck
doesn't hit me,
it was my faith.
So there are no conditions of the world
where whatever is instantiated is not my
faith.
Therefore,
fatalism is not part of the epistemology
of science.
Right.
Well,
so to speak to that point that we were
talking about earlier,
how when someone is anchored in a
position,
you can get them away from it.
So I talk and I have a section of my
book that is currently titled All Roads
Lead to bigotry.
All right,
so let me give you an example.
A few examples of these.
If you say that you don't want to have
sex with overweight women,
grossly overweight women,
500 pound women,
then the argument is you're a fattest
right?
You are judging us based on the folds of
our skin and you're demonizing us.
If you are someone who is specifically
looking to have sex with someone who is
overweight,
you are fetishizing our skin folds.
So if I love having sex with a fat
woman,
I'm a bad person.
If I don't want to have sex with a fat
woman,
I'm a bad person.
And I demonstrate through many of these
examples how all roads lead to
victimhood,
right?
I give the example.
I think the last time I was on the show
have a woman who had done a study
demonstrating that,
uh,
soldiers,
Israeli soldiers,
had never raped a Palestinian woman.
Do you remember that case?
Did.
Now she,
she had done the study hoping to show
that there was rampant rape of senior
women.
She couldn't uncover a single documented
case of a Palestinian woman being raped
by IDF soldiers,
Israeli Defense Forces,
soldiers.
What did you conclude from that?
While the IDF soldiers are so racist,
that they demonize these women so much
that they're not even worthy of being
raped.
So if you rape the Palestinian women,
you're an evil Jew.
If you don't rape any of the Palestinian
women,
you're an evil Jew.
And so through all of these examples,
I demonstrate that all states of the
world lead to you being a bigot.
And that if you like,
fails poppers,
falsification,
principle,
because I kept.
Yep.
Except the state of not choosing it all.
Meaning meaning if you like,
if you don't choose between a fat woman
or if you don't love a fat woman or you
don't not want to have sex with a fat
one,
you just have sex with anyone who wants
to have sex with you.
Right?
Like that's the equal outcome.
I mean,
essentially that's what they're looking
for it because if you don't choose.
But what's really interesting about
people is if someone doesn't have your
principals ideologically,
you're allowed to shit on them and body
shamed them.
Like how many people called
Trump's disgusting and made fun of his
little hands and how many liberals left
wing people's talking about how much,
much,
much.
He Ha must obviously have a little dick.
Right?
Right.
It's like,
yeah,
it's horseshit.
Yeah.
I mean,
hypocrisy is across both aisles,
right?
Yeah.
Speaking of which,
I don't know if you want to get into
this at all,
but uh,
what did you think,
I know it's a bit old news now,
but,
uh,
what'd you think of some of our common
friends?
His response to the threat cavenaugh
situation,
our common friends responses.
Some of some of our common friends,
I thought the not respond well,
they did not follow the into logical,
he fails as far as I'm concerned,
like for example.
So for example,
the presumption of innocence,
it should be something that is so
profoundly a nonstarter in terms of ever
violating that,
that tenant that to the extent that we
didn't come infinitely close to
establishing that he was guilty of
anything.
It's a nonstarter that you don't.
There is no repercussions that should be
followed him and yet many folks that
both of us.
No,
we're not of that opinion.
So for example,
one of the,
one of our friends thought that,
well,
this wasn't a criminal case,
this was a job interview,
and so we don't need to reach the same
exact thing,
level of evidence,
evidence to determine for him to be
potentially guilty.
I thought that was grotesque who said
that?
Uh,
his name rhymes with Sham Paris.
Well,
I think people were rightly concerned
about Cavanaugh's ideology in terms of
his record on privacy.
Uh,
his promotion of the Patriot Act.
There was a bunch of issues that people
had real concern.
Those seem to go away while this was all
going on,
which is really confusing to me,
like there's real reasons to be
concerned about this guy.
A Jordan Jordan said,
put out a tweet and I might've been the
first one to two a critique him for
where he said,
if Kevin is confirmed,
he should step down.
I thought that that was insane.
Why?
Why did he say?
He said,
well,
you know,
subsequently he said,
oh,
it was a thought experiment and no,
there's no thought experiment,
right?
I mean there wasn't any sane person
would think that someone coming out 36
years after the fact,
five minutes before there's going to be
the volt saying,
well,
somewhere somehow someplace.
Not sure he may have been.
The one is not going to.
She was saying he may have been the one
she was saying he was the one and she
was saying that he covered her mouth and
that he was trying to get her pants on,
but she was wearing a one piece swimsuit
and yeah,
I read into it.
I don't know what happened.
That's the real problem.
No one knows what happened other than
her and him and both of them are dealing
with 36 year old memory,
but I'm saying right here.
I've already said this on my show.
I remember,
I think it was in 1983.
I was at summer camp and Hillary Clinton
took me to the side and had my way.
Pretty sure it was 1983 maybe in 1984.
She had her way with you.
Sure.
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure it was hillary.
Pretty sure.
Uproot kindness kind of confident was
her.
Yeah.
Look,
Elizabeth Loftus,
who is someone that I know well who's a
professor at Uc Irvine,
who is the preeminent researcher on
memory and eye witness testimony,
uh,
as someone who has demonstrated through
many,
many decades of research that our memory
is unbelievably inaccurate.
Unbelievably.
Our ability to remember sort of to
identify someone in I testimony four
weeks ago is unbelievably suspect,
let alone 36 years ago.
That's true.
So where was the science?
Let me pause right there.
Because there are traumatic events that
you can remember very well.
Particularly if someone tries to assault
you or something happens to you that did
get seared into your brain.
That's a fact.
I mean,
I remember,
uh,
I remember being beat up when I was
seven.
Right?
I'm ever being humiliated.
My step dad and mom wasn't even really
beat up.
My Kid,
he'll hit me like once or twice or
something like that,
but I didn't do anything about it.
I froze and I remember my stepdad came
and rescued me.
I remember that.
Don't remember all the details,
but I do remember that I felt humiliated
and that I lost.
And I do remember that my Stepdad had a
rescue me.
I remember that.
Like you can remember stuff from 36
years ago is.
It is possible.
But the problem with this story is that
they were drinking.
There were underage.
They were really young.
Okay.
So you're dealing with all these
factors.
There was some sort of interaction
physically,
you know,
was she somewhat willing?
Will she somewhat into him?
Was she completely resistant to it?
I don't know.
She doesn't know.
He doesn't know,
but there's no demonstrated pattern of
him doing awful things.
And then on top of that,
there was a couple,
at least two people that had completely
fraudulent claims that came out and they
were ideologically,
ideologically opposed to him.
So they had concocted these stories that
turned out to fall apart.
Here's my feeling on that.
If someone does that intentionally,
they should receive the same kind of
punishment.
I could not agree with that.
Someone would get,
if they were convicted of those acts
written an article on this actually
strips.
If you,
if you falsely accuse someone of rape,
intentionally,
falsely accuse someone of rape,
you are literally subjecting them to the
punishment of rape.
What if the prosecution goes through?
What if that person winds up getting
incarcerated,
locked in a cage,
separated from their family,
kids taken away their ability to earn a
living?
You should be treated the same way you
were trying to get them to be treated.
I think it is almost an equal act to
rape itself.
You know,
and I hope I almost,
I hope not,
doesn't have physical violence.
I'm going to go further than you.
Maybe it's going to get me into trouble.
I almost would argue that it is more
diabolical because the rapist does a
horrific act on you once every single
morning that you wake up as a false
accuser knowing that you have put this
person in prison and you go about your
day,
you're engaging in this form of rape if
you'd like,
so I would disagree with that because I
think if you rape someone,
that person who got raped has to deal
with that.
The real pain of being physically
violated.
The guy who was in prison for 25 years
in getting raped by seven guys,
guys got to learn how to fight and keep
your butt cheeks closed and keep moving.
And by the way,
both of them are awful.
I think the rapist is far more awful
because it's physically doing something.
I had a guy on my show maybe you know,
I've had maybe not as many people as you
have,
but I've had quite a few amazing people
on my show.
One of the most poignant ones was a
gentleman that I invited and I was lucky
that he accepted my invitation.
Was his,
I think his name is David Mccallum.
Mccallum a sort of maybe last January.
He had just.
He had been released from I think almost
three decades in prison for a murder
that came up.
That wasn't him who did it.
Now.
The reason why I invited him a more than
just because it's an incredible story is
that I had seen his response to the
unimaginable injustice that he had gone
through.
I think he went in when he was 17 and
now he was in his late forties and he
had such grace,
such lack of anger.
I mean it literally was.
He was Buddha and so I thought how
powerful it would be to have this person
come on my show if only to tap into
this.
Unbelievable.
I mean,
and I told them,
I think on the show that if it were me,
I would be so eaten up by anger,
by a sense of revenge.
I want to burn the whole planet down a.
anyways,
this is a great guy.
You should definitely check him out.
He's written a book about it.
It's really an amazing story.
Yeah.
False accusations are awful and and and
people who are people who lie to try to
punish someone who didn't do anything,
that's an awful crime and I think it
should be equal in punishment to the
crime that you are falsely accusing
someone of doing.
I really do.
I think that's the only way to stop it.
The real problem was with false rape
accusations is that there's very little
punishment at all that happens to the
women for the most part,
or the men,
men who are accused men of falsely
raping them.
There's very,
very little happen.
Why?
Why do you think that is?
I don't know.
I don't understand.
I don't understand why people don't
think about it as the horrific thing
that it actually is.
I think it's partly because people are
of doubting someone who has been raped,
if you will.
One of the more horrific things you
could do is like imagine if you had been
raped and then you told your story and I
came along and I have no knowledge of
the actual event and I come along and I
go,
God's a liar.
This is bullshit.
It never happened.
Nothing happened to him,
he's just a baby.
He just wants attention.
So he's running around here.
He was wearing a short skirt and he went
out that night and you know,
and that's,
that is something that does happen.
So I think that is so disgusting.
Someone who doubts someone who has
actually been a victim,
that people are scared of that.
And then also there's the kid gloves
approach.
We don't treat women accusing men of
things the same way we accused women
accused men accusing women of things.
Men accusing women to things where if a
man accuses a woman of violence,
will you okay dude,
you're going to be fine.
If a woman beats up her husband,
which does happen.
I mean I know a guy whose girlfriend
used to punch the shit out of him and I
was like,
Bro,
you got to get out like you are.
You're literally being abused.
You're,
you're being domestically abused and no
one's even going to care.
Do you understand that?
You've got to get out of this
relationship because look,
if you are hitting her,
if a man is hitting a woman,
then I'm locked that motherfucker up.
That's how I feel,
and I'm sure that's how you feel too.
That guy's a piece of shit.
But if a woman hits a man,
I'm like,
just keep your hands up,
man.
Don't let her hit.
Yeah,
I just,
but this is from me.
A man whose friend was murdered by his
wife.
One of my good friends.
Oh,
Phil Hartman.
More by his wife.
So this is a woman who was always
insulting him,
always publicly humiliated.
Saw this during her publicly humiliated,
insult him.
I sought many times.
She's a very angry person.
She had a cocaine problem.
She was also on Zoloft.
They want some sort of a settlement with
zoloft.
The family did because she was doing
cocaine and Zoloft at the same time and
it's known to have a psychotic reaction,
but she shot him in his fucking sleep,
man.
I mean,
women do commit violence.
It's not as common,
but it's still gross.
It's still an egregious crime,
but good luck trying to go get someone
locked up for it.
Good luck getting anybody to be
sympathetic.
Even me.
Did you ever.
I mean,
not that I have your.
Well,
I met your wife.
She's a lovely woman.
If she kicked your ass,
I'll probably be on her side.
You're probably wondering how.
How is someone so gorgeous as her choose
me?
You're,
you're thinking that I know.
Have you out of here.
Thank you buddy.
I wanted to actually share with you and
I was.
I was hoping to only discuss this for
you to only see it in the book,
but I can't.
You open me up,
Joe Rogan.
I can't help but cheer.
I came close to probably being a victim
of some very serious.
I've never been sexually abused or
anything,
but I think I escaped one narrowly,
uh,
when I was a child in Lebanon.
Oh,
so this was during
the civil war.
This is all discussed in the intro to my
forthcoming book.
Uh,
it was during the height of the Ami,
the start of the civil war where nobody
would leave the house.
I mean,
everybody's been butchered,
left,
right,
and center.
We're trying to leave Lebanon for
obvious reasons.
My father had been stuck out of the
country.
He couldn't get back into Lebanon.
It was myself,
my mother,
uh,
I believe my sister was there and a male
friend of ours who was stuck at our
house.
And in the middle of the night there's a
knock on our door now.
This is in the middle of the most brutal
civil war you could imagine.
So if somebody knocks at your door,
it's usually not a good thing.
And the,
I go to the door to answer,
speaking about remembering,
you were saying earlier,
this is,
I'm 11 years old,
uh,
or at least at the cusp of turning 11,
I get to the door.
Who is this?
Uh,
the gentleman says it's me.
I can't remember if his name was
Mohammed,
one of the two.
He says,
it's so and so.
Who's this now?
At the time in Lebanon,
in our kitchen we had.
Do you remember how in restaurants in
the old days you'd have these in the
bathrooms,
you'd have these sort of towels that you
could use to wipe your hands?
Not,
not,
not disposable time,
actual cloth towels.
So we had a service where this gentleman
with come and in our kitchen we had one
of these days he would pick them up,
launder them,
and then bring them back.
So this gentleman who that's our only
relationship with him,
knocks at our door with some other guys
and says,
hey,
open the door now.
This is in the middle of the civil war.
Now if at that moment I opened that
door,
if I don't have the instinct to go call
my mother,
I don't know what the trajectory would
be,
so I go to get my mother and now the
guy's growing more insistent.
We call anyways.
There's a whole interaction that takes
place,
but we refuse to open the door for him.
At the time there was still some sort of
police presence in Lebanon.
The unit used to be called 16 in Arabic.
The number 16 maybe for the precinct or
whatever we call them up.
They come over,
the guy comes in and the the policeman
says to him,
what are you doing here?
Knocking on people's door in the middle
of the civil war says,
oh,
we went up to the mountains.
We brought some Pama grades for them and
so the police man looks at him and says,
you don't know these people other than
changing their towel in the middle of
this brutal civil war.
You're coming here to give them these
fruits.
If I ever catch you here again,
you know,
whatever.
And then the guy looks at us and says,
I'll be back for you or something.
That.
And within a week or two,
I can't remember the exact time period
we had left.
Now I'm almost certain,
I don't know,
I'm surmising,
but I'm almost certain that this guy
with his buddies was coming over,
not because he wanted to share a coffee
and cookies and my feeling is some bad
stuff would have happened that night.
But through the grace of the cosmos,
we were protected.
So because I've.
I've often been asked what was the
scariest moment you had in the civil
war,
and there were many,
many,
many things that I saw,
but nothing scared me as much as that
interaction because I sort of pretty
much knew what was in store for us.
Dehumanizing that happens during war
leads to all sorts of horrific acts,
you know,
it's disgusting and scary,
uh,
you,
you probably dodged a bullet.
I related the logical and we're so
fortunate to have left.
I've,
I've actually been asked to go back to
Lebanon many times and at this point by
some pretty prominent people,
big politicians and so on,
and I really have a mental block.
I even get Lebanese folks saying,
listen,
we,
we know people who will protect you.
And so on.
I do.
Do you live in Canada?
Announced one of the greatest countries
in the world's ever known.
Why?
Go back?
Yeah.
Fuck that.
You guys come to me.
Come visit Toronto.
The Fuck Outta here.
Toronto's amazing.
He likes it.
I love it.
It's one of my favorite cities.
You know,
one of the things I love about it,
it's like a big city,
but the people are friendly,
like it's a small town.
Right?
I don't know how the hell you guys
pulled that off.
We're just good people.
Do you feel.
Do you feel a difference between
Montreal and Toronto?
Because Toronto better.
Sorry,
Montrio.
You heard me pull?
I do.
I like what?
What is it that you don't like about
Michelle?
I do love Montreal.
Montreal.
It is the conflict.
Like the French English.
Yeah.
That conflict seems to me silly.
Ridiculous.
The idea that you're going to succeed.
Yeah.
Good luck.
Yeah,
get you're going to leave Canada.
Okay.
Congratulations going to be your own
country that nobody goes to.
Right?
We're going to make everybody speak
French.
That's so stupid.
In the main.
They put French signs everywhere I get.
They're trying to like cling onto their
culture.
I get it and the culture is wonderful.
The food's fantastic.
There's great people in Montreal.
Beautiful women.
Yeah,
they're beautiful.
I Love Montreal,
but I love to run a more.
Sorry.
Incidentally,
I'm,
I learned French before I did English,
so I'm a more francophone through,
through history and I fully agree with
you about the stupidity of the French
protection.
So I,
so yeah,
I was invited once.
This was probably in the late nineties.
I had been a professor a few years.
I was invited by,
uh,
one of the big business schools in
Montreal.
AGC,
uh,
which is a French acronym.
I'd been invited to give a talk there.
They were interested in potentially
making me an offer and so I said,
are you,
I'm,
I'm assuming that I'm getting my talking
in English,
right?
Because I mean,
my whole scientific career has been in
English even though I'm fluent in
French.
He said,
no,
we'd really like you to give it in
French.
And I thought that that was so paisanos
parochial.
It was so small minded.
Right.
I mean,
you don't see Israeli people saying,
hey,
how come we're not doing this in Hebrew?
You don't see the Japanese saying,
why isn't this happening in Japanese?
Right.
The two groups that I see doing this are
the Germans
and the French,
uh,
but whether it be in Quebec or in
France,
and I think it's in part because they
don't accept that they no longer the big
bully of the world.
Right.
The positive side would be that they're
just celebrating this language.
They appreciate their heritage,
but you shouldn't be protecting your
heritage through draconian means.
Correct.
So when you have language police going
around measuring whether the French sign
is bigger than the English one,
you're getting stuck in the weeds,
right?
Yeah.
That is a weird one that they do,
but it's such a beautiful city and the
people were really nice there too.
And they're hardy people in Montreal and
Toronto.
They're hardy folk because the winter,
I think it mentioned,
yeah,
you got to deal with shit.
You got to deal with adversity over
there.
But it's interesting in that there is so
much nicer than the people that deal
with the adversity in the cold climates
in,
in America.
There's something about the United
States when you deal with the cold
climate,
people are mean.
I've been asked,
and I don't think I had an answer,
maybe,
I think it was rubin who asked me,
why do you think that many of the sort
of people on the forefront of the
freedom of speech,
you know,
the debate all stem from Canada and I
don't think I had a good reason.
Do you have any,
any thoughts as to why is it just a
freedom of speech laws,
right?
That's one of the reasons so that it
does not have a first amendment.
So Canada is not have the same with what
we have here in the United States is
fucking beautiful.
It's one of the only places on earth
where it is literally a part of our law
that you should be able to express
yourself freely and that this ethic is
something that permeates our culture.
It permeates our identity.
It's something that we all cling to.
Freedom of speech is a very important.
And this is one of the reasons why we
get so stunned when we see censorship
and when we see censorship that's just
doesn't make any sense,
right?
It's not justified.
Um,
what you guys have over there is a much
more slippery slope,
human rights councils and all that
weirdness that we've seen time and time
again with people getting fined for
jokes.
You know what I mean?
There's,
there's a lot of like very,
very weird stuff that you guys have to
deal with up there because you simply
don't have a first amendment.
So you're saying that,
that,
that causes more people to come out of
kind of the defending freedom of speech
because because you realize how
important it is and you're right next to
us,
right?
You're right.
We're all spouting off at the mouth and
fucking shoot nuclear bombs into the
atmosphere.
I mean,
this,
you're living next to a bunch of fucking
wild hillbillies is what it's like.
This is what it's like.
If you're living in Canada,
you're living next to the United States.
Like what are those fucking crazy
assholes doing?
But at least those crazy ass schools can
say whatever they want.
Right?
I mean,
who knows if this podcast would be even
possible in Canada,
I don't know.
I,
we could have gotten
in trouble for some of the things that
we've said along the way.
It's entirely likely a speaking of,
uh,
because you,
you mentioned the human rights tribunal.
I think at one point a I discussed on
the show the indigenous woman who argued
that she should get tenure despite not
having published anything.
Do you,
do you know that story?
Don't let me,
let me,
let me restate that story or maybe state
it for the first time because it,
it relates to something bigger than I'd
like to discuss in the Canadian context.
So there's this now push and Canadian
universities to have what's called to
indigenize.
The university's okay.
To indigenize means many things.
So in one case,
the case that I just mentioned briefly
before,
you had a professor in the law faculty
at the University of British Columbia
who was an indigenous woman who had not
published much,
if anything and had got,
had,
had been given every single opportunity,
you know,
extensions on her tenure clock and so
on.
And then finally,
when she didn't get tenure,
she filed a complaint with the British
Columbia human rights tribunal arguing
that her tradition is an oral one,
and therefore by forcing her to write
things down,
you know,
as a,
as an academic wise,
right?
I mean it's unbelievable.
So saying her tradition is being on land
and you shouldn't be forcing you to swim
in a swimming event.
Exactly right.
By the way,
Judaism is based also on oral tradition.
So by that logic,
all those Jewish scientists who won
Nobel prizes,
but the more nefarious manifestation of
and the generalization,
while there are two other instances,
one annoying but not so serious,
and one I think very serious,
the annoying but not so serious is where
now at every single event and can't.
And Canadian University,
let's say you're giving out diplomas,
you have to first sell flagellate at an
apologize for sitting on stolen land,
right?
So here are students who have spent
years getting their degrees.
This is their moment to shine.
This is about them.
But you have to first hear about why
we're all evil because we've
transgressing on native land.
That's one example.
The more serious example is where it is
no longer appropriate to say that the
scientific method is the way of knowing
that there are alternate ways of knowing
that are just as valid and what are
those.
So for example,
in the indigenous way of knowing,
uh,
now I've argued that when it comes to
content specific knowledge,
for example,
if you're going to study something in
the deep north where the inuits have
lived for thousands of years,
they're going to have local knowledge
about the flora,
about the fauna.
That is truly a valuable.
But that's,
that is in fact scientific knowledge.
But exactly,
that's exactly what.
But,
but,
but I'm saying that,
that's why I'm saying it's a content
specific.
Okay.
We should be appreciative of that
knowledge and listened to it,
but that doesn't mean that speaks to
your point that it is outside the
purview of the scientific method.
There is no episode homology that there
is no Lebanese Jewish way of knowing.
There is no Joe Rogan way of knowing.
There isn't any transgender way of
knowing this information.
It's just the scientific method that's
the only game in town.
While they're arguing that,
no,
there are ways of not just like the
Hashtag science must fall.
I mentioned this on the Ruben report,
judge agreement with this Hashtag
seismic fault.
Yeah.
This is what's going to rise.
They're called,
they're called [inaudible].
Actually this is.
This came out of the University of Cape
Town,
one of the top universities in South
Africa where the students were arguing
that it is ridiculous that we only abide
by the scientific method.
There are all sorts of other Booga Booga
ways of knowing that are just.
I mean,
I'm using google.
Yeah,
but you know what I mean,
right.
You could dance and make the rain come
down,
you know,
whatever.
I mean it like spiritual shamanism,
ways of knowing that are,
that are outside the purview of the
scientific method and that is grotesque.
And so one of the things that I argue
probably doesn't make me a lot of
friends at the university is that there
is no indigenous way of knowing,
please.
She's Google.
Hashtag science must fall.
I need to remember those.
He a website for know your meme and I
got the video of where it starts.
There you go.
See,
doctor,
sad proves to be true.
Again,
I have a feeling this is a four Chan
thing that's real,
or three years old.
He's made that largest in my shitty
eyes.
Could read it.
Science must fall as a Hashtag mocking a
movement to abolish the science.
Oh,
it's marketing.
No,
but the original idea is that you should
decolonize your mind.
I understand,
but it's mocking that movement,
mocking a movement to abolish the
scientific method and replace it with a
new understanding of scientific inquiry.
This movement was started by a group of
students known as follows at the
University of Cape Town who want to
decolonize science from Western
modernity as an offshoot of the ongoing
fees must fall movement protesting
increases in university tuition.
That's one thing.
Can I ask going forward to know that you
guys have tuition way lower healthcare
and student.
We pay for it with taxes,
right?
Yeah,
but it's worth it.
I mean,
I've said time and time.
Look,
I,
I believe in the hybrid form of,
of governing.
In a hybrid form of culture,
and I think that,
um,
I've supported a lot of socialized ideas
and one of the reasons why is because I
see socialism work with the fire
department,
with the police department,
with,
with things that we all agreed that
we're going to chip in and pay for,
and the fact that we don't do this with
healthcare,
that,
you know,
if my neighbor gets sick,
the community has to chip in.
God dammit,
that guy's been paying taxes his whole
life.
He's a viable part of the community.
We should be taking care of our own.
This should be a primary thing like
this.
To strengthen our community,
to strengthen our civilization.
One of the primary things you wish you'd
be taking care of each other physically.
There should be like above.
All right?
Education.
You shouldn't have to fucking be in
debt.
A quarter million dollars.
If you get a fucking education.
Don't we want less losers?
Don't we want more people to have
education?
Do we want more people to have some sort
of pathway to success?
Wouldn't that just logically lead to a,
a stronger economy,
a stronger communities?
Stronger civilization when it was that
logical.
Let me give a devil's advocate advocate
answer to the extent that they are now,
no longer any barriers to entry to get
into university.
Certainly in Canada at least not a
financial one.
You get,
I think a misallocation of talent and
resources where everybody feels
compelled to go to university where in
reality many of the folks in question
and believe me,
I'm the last guy to argue against
education,
right?
I'm all about lifelong learning,
but it doesn't have to be through the
formal channels of getting a degree,
but that's not compulsory at.
Well it is compulsory unofficially in
that it is now no longer acceptable to
not have at least some entry level
degree.
Well then we should concentrate on that
as an issue.
Right?
Okay.
That should be the issue.
Not this idea that somehow or another
education should be expensive so it
should be difficult.
So it should be something that it's only
sought out by people.
Fair enough.
So.
So I agree.
It should.
The barrier to entry shouldn't be that,
you know,
it's the finances that don't allow you
to pursue your interests,
but I know,
I mean just as a professor for 25 years
now,
there are students that I see very early
and in a given semester that I know
they're not there or they're not there
for intrinsic reasons.
They just don't have the sparkle in
their eyes and no amount of coaxing on
my part is ever going to bring them out.
I mean I try,
I think everybody's redeemable,
but you can tell that they're there
because they don't have.
Maybe those people would have had a much
more lucrative trajectory where they
pursue trade school.
So.
So I think we have to also be careful
about how to allocate the talent that we
have.
I know that that absolutely makes sense
and I think that is most likely played
out over the difficulty of pursuing an
education.
Right?
Just like it is with everything else.
Everything else,
like whatever,
whatever you want to be a standup
comedian.
It's not everybody gets to do Carnegie
Hall.
Like there's,
there's a,
there's a weeding out process of the
difficulty of achieving success and
there's a lot of people that fall by the
wayside and don't make it and this is
just natural.
It's a natural part of the process,
but if you say not everybody is a
comedian,
that's true,
but open mike nights available to
everybody.
True and that's why there's so many
comedians that actually are good because
they do find it through because there's
no financial barrier to entry.
If it
costs $35,000
a year to pursue an education in comedy
and you had to be $200,000
in debt before you could make a living
on the road,
right?
There wouldn't be a goddamn thing.
The laugh at there wouldn't be none of
us.
There'd be zero of us and that's not a
good x.
it's not a good example because
obviously comedy is one of the rare
things that is self-educated process.
You have to yourself taught.
There's no other way.
You just have to pursue it,
but I think there's the rigidness of
university studies,
you know,
the rigidness of courses of,
of determining what people should and
shouldn't learn what they should and
shouldn't be educated in who also the
randomness of the professors that you
get.
Like you could get you and get a
wonderful education I'm sure.
Or you get some dipshit and get taught
about how gender is a social construct
and you know,
you're sitting in class all baffled
looking at your penis going,
what have you done to me fucking
monster.
You know,
it's,
I'm at the point now in my career as a
professor where I'm facing a bit of a
fork and that I remain as passionate
about teaching students,
but the meat,
this medium,
right.
Appearing on Joe Rogan and then having
10 million people watch and maybe maybe
be excited about evolutionary psychology
is so much of a bigger platform that it
causes me at times a bit of an angst
when I have to put in all the efforts
that I have to put in to teach a class
of 14 people.
Not that each of those mines is not
worthy of being educated and being
inspired and so on.
Uh,
but I am facing at this point in my
career,
you know,
I'm a mid career point in my life where
I could turn on my laptop and put up
anything and you know,
25,000
people will watch it.
This is nothing compared to your farm,
but it's $25,000
in terms of his classroom size.
Exactly.
Arena full of people.
And so I think that's one of the things
that,
uh,
I now struggle with.
I always remain as passionate once I
walk into class.
I'm just as passionate just as
committed.
But to the extent that we have this
fixed pie of time,
it becomes so difficult to ever have the
twelfth students went out against the 12
million students.
Here would be my perspective and maybe
this can enhance this experience for
you.
I would treat it the same way that a
comedian treats performing live.
Like I do this podcast and every time I
do this podcast,
I'm reaching millions of people.
What if I decided,
well,
you know what?
I can't do the improv anymore.
It's only 190 people do the comedy
store.
It's only 400 people in the main room.
That's not,
that's too good analogy.
Too small,
but doing that,
doing,
you know,
the belly room,
70 people in the comedy store,
belly room,
doing those little small room hones your
skills.
It actually keeps you tied into people
too.
It keeps you engaged with individual
human beings.
It keeps you real.
It's interesting that you say that is
because uh,
this,
uh,
I had an MBA,
I was teaching mba course this semester
where we had to miss two classes,
one because it was Canadian thanksgiving
on a Monday,
and then there was the provincial
Canadian thanksgiving can.
What does that mean?
The real Thanksgiving first or ours?
Ours is the second Monday in October.
That's ridiculous,
right?
Yours is also called a Greenbay plays
Dallas.
That's called American thanksgiving
called November 24th mother fucker or
whatever it is,
Thursday,
November.
So this Mba class was being taught on
Monday.
So I missed one Monday because of
thanksgiving.
And I missed the second Monday because
it was the official provincial election
in Quebec and by university decree we
had to cancel classes.
And so the way that I made up those
classes and I asked the students as I
said,
well,
you could come in on a Sunday as the
university has dictated or we,
I could post them,
post the lectures online.
And then eventually I asked them would
you prefer if I posted all my lectures
online and then I came in and did other
stuff in class or would you prefer that
I actually deliver the material live in
front of you?
And actually a lot of them answered in a
way similar to what you just said,
which is there is something intimate
about delivering the message right there
physically,
tangibly,
that you can't capture online 100
percent live performance in any way,
shape or form.
Whether it's music or comedy or,
uh,
I mean,
I think teaching is informed a form of
live performance,
but is when you have someone who's
disinterested and listless and just say
they have no energy and they're teaching
even if the information is fascinating.
It's very difficult to absorb,
whereas if you have someone like
yourself who's passionate and engaging
and articulate and they have live to
you,
like it's fun.
It makes the educational experience
something that it.
It's,
it's,
it's a performance art.
It really is.
It is.
You know what pisses me off when I
received the teaching evaluations,
I usually,
I get there.
They're great.
I scored very well,
but once in a while you get someone who
enters something that you know is a lie.
So I'll give you an example.
Someone says he wasn't accessible to his
students.
Well,
the reality is there wasn't a single
time that a student ever asked to meet
me either during office hours or if they
can't make office hours outside of
office hours,
we could do a skype chat,
we could do a phone chat.
I've never said I'm not meeting you.
I don't have time with.
It's never happened yet.
Someone because they are protected by
the cloak of anonymity because the
teaching evaluations are done
anonymously,
can write whatever they want and there
is no opportunity for you to reboot.
Now,
of course,
the reality is this has no effect on my
career.
I mean I could easily say,
who cares what they say,
but I do care because probably like you,
you'd like to think that every single
person in that audience is going to
hopefully find you funny and they walked
away,
entertained,
you know,
because of your set and there's no way
for me to rebut them.
Well,
especially when someone's
lying about that,
that's really annoying,
but I feel like it's like yelp scores.
You ever ever read yelp reviews?
Like you read them and you'll see all
these wonderful reviews.
The restaurant was incredible.
The food was fantastic.
The decor,
everything about it.
The waitress was amazing.
The chef came over to our table and
greeted us.
It was so good and then you'll see one
person,
everyone was rude.
My food was like,
wait when it was this the same place.
And then.
So what I always love to do,
one of my favorite things to do on yelp
is I will go to a restaurant and if I'm
interested in this restaurant and go,
wow,
look at this,
got four and a half stars,
that's fucking great,
and then I'll find a one star and I go,
okay,
let me click on their profile and you
will see a fucking tornado of one star
reviews of everybody with everything.
Fucking laundromats.
Grocery stores.
They hate everything.
It's so universal.
It's so common.
And then occasionally like one four star
review of something like a movie theater
or something like that.
They're probably on adderall that day or
something.
It's.
It's fucking weird.
It's weird how many malcontents are out
there just bouncing off of things and
just angry at the world,
honking their horn and traffic and
writing one star reviews.
I've actually thought of starting a
project and I had a research assistant
look at it.
Preemptive,
not exploring it for me.
You tell me what you think of this
hypothesis.
So you have one star to five stars,
let's say on Amazon,
on travel,
expedia,
whatever it's called,
hotels,
restaurants.
Do you think that the amount of words
that people use across the five stars
changes?
In other words,
for example,
hypothesis might be the more negative
the review,
the more words are used because.
And so probably I hope nobody steals
this idea because that's an idea that
I'm hoping to test a soon.
Oh,
scientifically.
Right?
So if you look.
Yeah,
I know what I'm saying.
So yes.
Yeah.
So you.
So your prediction would.
There's a thing on it already.
No Way.
Statistical difference between one star
and five star reviews on yelp.
There we go.
Make that large place.
What year was this?
Twenty 14.
You're way behind,
bro.
Many businesses in the real world
encourage customers to rate on yelp.
Yelp,
the best way to find local businesses
relies on user reviews to help the
viewers find the best places.
Both positive and negative reviews are
helpful in this mission.
Positive reviews on yelp.
I go back to what the thing was.
Yeah,
no,
but what I'm seeing or statistical
differences in the amount of text just
text,
right.
It's not a part of this.
Is that a part of the review?
Is that what they're saying?
Put it up,
getting into types of words,
generalize the language,
present.
Um,
but,
but blah,
blah,
Blah and one,
125,458
yelp reviews using the data sheet
containing reviews of businesses and
Phoenix,
Asa,
blah,
blah blah.
Okay.
When comparing the most frequent two
word phrases.
Okay,
but this is just the content,
but that's also probably safe Jamie,
but look at that one star is so there's
certain words that come up and run star.
That's not what it is though.
Good,
great.
Happy and contrast at one star.
Yelp reviews,
uh,
use very little positive language and
instead discuss the amount of minutes,
presumably much for this first section
is only two word reviews.
The next section here is three word
reviews.
And so he goes on further.
Yeah,
go back to where I was reading there.
It says very little.
So five star yelp reviews contain many
instances of good.
Great,
good.
Contrast the one star,
yelp reviews,
but,
but here's what's interesting.
Use very little positive language,
but instead discussed the amount of
minutes,
presumably long and unfortunate waits at
the establishment.
That's interesting.
Las Vegas,
one of the cities where the reviewers
were collected,
which is why appears prominently so I
don't have more people have to wait.
Yeah,
that's,
if that makes sense.
You were talking about the amount of
words in the review itself.
Let me take,
let me throw that in there at all the
size of the,
um,
just the size of their review because
this is a statistical analysis of the,
uh,
the words content you.
Exactly.
But anyway,
let me tell you the background.
So I published a paper in 2014 in a
journal called evolution human behavior
where we looked at.
Just give me a chance to give you a bit
of background.
So remember I talked earlier about the
framing effect.
If she,
if I tell you that a burger is 10
percent fat versus 90 percent fat free,
it's the same description.
It's just one way you frame it
positively,
negatively.
So I took this idea with one of my
former doctoral students and we applied
it to the context of mating.
So for example,
if I tell you you can go out on a date
with this woman and seven out of 10 of
her acquaintances thinks she's
intelligent.
This is exactly like telling you that
three out of 10 of her friends didn't
think she's intelligent.
Right?
So I could either frame the information
positively or negatively.
It's the exact same information and this
is called the framing effect because
just how you frame something causes
people to change their evaluation of the
person.
Okay.
And so what we want to know is whether
men or women are more likely to succumb
to the framing effect within a meeting
context.
Do you follow what I'm saying?
Yes.
Well before I.
I'm not to put you on the spot,
but I guess I will.
Can you predict which of the two sexes
is more likely to fall prey to the
framing manipulation specifically in the
main context?
Emails fairy good.
You're an evolutionary psychologist.
White women or men don't mind.
And then.
Well that's not quite friends.
Say she's a con.
Yeah,
but that's because she's got no,
none of that's not.
That's not the reason.
The reason is because negatively framed
information,
and this is how I'm going to tie it to
the study.
Negative information,
right?
Negatively framed information looms
larger and the psyche of women
specifically in the mating domain
precisely because making a poor choice
has greater consequences evolutionarily
speaking for the woman,
the exactly.
So this is called the parental
investment theory,
so we took parental investment theory
and applied it in this context to the
framing the decision and showed that
when it comes specifically to the
maitland context,
women are more likely to succumb to the
framing effect that makes sense.
And and,
and the reason again stems from the fact
that there is what's called a negative
negativity bias for this.
The same valence information looms
larger when it's negative.
Then it's once Fazio,
precisely because we've evolved to pay
more attention to negative information
rather than positive information.
And so that got me thinking about that
hypothesis that I just told you,
which is in the consumer context,
do I spend more time as a consumer
trying to justify my very negative
decision?
And therefore that's why I got the word
hypothesis.
If any bastard steals that hypothesis,
I'm going to know the godfather always
knows there's more into this is a very
long article that it doesn't do what I
believe it does right here is the amount
of words in the review has a lesser
negative affect review that is 333 words
indicates a onestar decreased,
but the average amount of words in the
yelp reviews 130 words.
So the more words,
the more likely it is to have a negative
one star review.
So it's already there.
So they aren't they.
They did a multifaceted analysis.
The model experienced 25 point 98
percent of the variation in the number
of stars given in a review.
This sounds like a low percentage,
but it's impressive for such a simple
model using unstructured real world
data.
Right?
This,
this,
by the way,
comes from a another principle which
basically says that when companies are
trying to pay attention to people how
satisfied they are,
one dissatisfied customer ends up having
much larger influence than one satisfied
customer because if you like the metric
velocity of someone who's pissed as much
greater than the possible certainly,
and that's why people were terrified of
bad reviews and you know they don't
really take too much.
Here's a problem.
This is a real problem.
I'm fake reviews.
There's a lot of companies and employ
these really unscrupulous humans who
will write fake reviews for your
business.
They were really positive reviews and
make it look like your business is
amazing and I guarantee you they use
very few words because they just try to
bang them out.
They just have a bunch of fake bullshit
accounts and you can pay someone and
there's.
There's services that do that.
Is there any way your restaurant,
is there any way to algorithmically
identify who the fake review because of
the structure
of the words they use are the
grammatical.
So where you know at somehow fake is.
I don't think so because I don't think
the fake reviews are done with a Bot.
I think it's done with actual human
sitting.
Okay.
Honestly,
I mean maybe if you notice it's in
English because they're all done in
India or something like that.
I think a lot of it is just people
finding a loophole in the system.
I actually heard someone discussing it
in a restaurant.
We in a restaurant waiting to seat and
this guy was telling the owner of the
restaurant,
you know,
I have a service that can,
that I know of that can help you,
and they'll just leave you great reviews
and it's an a,
you know,
you have an amazing restaurant.
I mean,
you should,
you should use this and he.
It's not like you're lying to the
people.
The food's good.
Like people have all these weird
justice,
but that again speaks to
consequentialism versus the
anthological.
Right?
Sure.
I mean,
if I were to point to a fault that I
have,
it's probably other than perfectionism,
is that my mother used to always say,
you need to realize that the world is
not as pure as the purity bubble that
you live in,
and so for example,
for me to lose weight through a
liposuction is a form of cheating
because if I don't go through the actual
process of consciously altering my
behavior,
I don't care about the end result.
The fact that you will say,
Hey,
you look really nice and thin.
Now the fact that I did it through quote
an artificial way,
to me it doesn't count.
Do you think that that's too brutal of a
standard or would you support.
Now,
not only is it not too brutal of a
standard,
it's actually based in logic because the
people that don't alter their behavior
but instead get liposuction almost
always wind up putting that fat back on
because they have to change your
behavior.
Right?
They have an issue with their patterns.
Yeah.
You know the number one pattern.
If someone is thinking about losing
weight,
the number one pattern that I would
always encourage people to do besides
changing their diet to a reduced
radically reduce the amount of sugar and
bread and pasta they which will in and
of itself eliminate a lot of weight,
is intermittent fasting,
meaning have a timed feeding window,
give yourself eight hours a day and eat
what you want to eat for eight hours,
but when that eight hours is done,
you don't eat for 16 hours and that is.
That is law,
so you just decide what that time window
is.
You decide when you're going to start
eating during the day,
based on when you want to eat dinner and
when you're done.
When you put that fork down,
there is 16 hours between then and the
time you ever stuff food in your face.
Again,
just doing that,
you will lose a lot of weight and it's a
healthy way to do it and and it's and
it's mimicking or closer mimic of our
evolutionary reality.
Yes,
our evolutionary reality.
You did not have shelves where food was
available everywhere in pantries and
refrigerators and superimpose a strong
proponent.
This is a plug for,
for a friend,
uh,
who's
the antifragile guy,
Nassim Taleb as a WHO's also Lebanese by
the way,
uh,
someone who's into this intermittent
fasting.
And I think he swears by it,
if I'm not mistaken,
the yes,
a lot of people do.
I do a,
I've had many,
many nutritionists and people that study
the science of nutritional absorption
and science of fasting.
There's a real science to fast and Dom
D'agostino has done some extensive work
on the positive benefits of fasting.
So it was Rhonda.
Patrick has discussed this in depth,
but I'm intermittent fasting.
And that timed feeding window is just,
it's so critical if you can just do
that.
I had a friend of mine,
his dad just lost 100 pounds doing that
over the last year and a half.
Yeah.
He alters diet,
you know,
just decided he needed to lose weight.
But the big one is he had a time to
window and that time to Windows eight
hours per day.
I organized in,
um,
I think it was in April,
a mini summit on health promotion from
an evolutionary perspective,
and so I invited several physicians who
are very sympathetic to the evolutionary
approach,
uh,
in terms of identifying ways by which we
can promote health whilst recognizing
some of these evolutionary imperatives.
Maybe I could share one or two.
Sure.
So it turns out,
for example,
that Gino,
who is the,
when you look at young men who suffer
from erectile dysfunction,
do you know what's the one behavior that
these young men,
because usually of course did I tell
this function is something that is more
prevalent as you get older,
for you to have to suffer from this
condition as a young man is an anomaly.
What do you think is the one behavior
that they share?
Um,
it's quite obvious what.
So a behavior that's really the true
mental to your health.
Think of the worst one.
Alcohol,
no worse.
Lack of sleep.
Worse drugs,
smoking,
smoking.
Yeah.
So heavy smokers are likely to be the
ones who are a director.
As far as young people.
Overall vitality has probably decreased.
And that's one of the side effects,
or their body is probably like,
bitch,
you're so sick,
you shouldn't be breeding as a matter
fact,
there's some interesting studies looking
at,
uh,
you know,
how erect your penis has as a function,
I say,
as a metric of your overall health.
But anyways,
uh,
and so I had mentioned this in several
lectures and then it actually came out
in a promotional campaign.
I don't know if they watch my lectures.
This is,
I think Health Canada where they had a,
uh,
advertisement with simply a cigarette
that's limp.
That was it.
That's the whole now that is exactly
what an evolutionary health promotion
approach would be like.
And let me explain why.
The typical approach with these types of
social marketing campaigns is provide
people with more information and that
would cause them to alter their behavior
if they're behaving in a maladaptive
way,
if you like.
It's because they didn't know any
better.
So tell them the likelihood of them
suffering heart disease when they're 73.
But the reality of course,
is that when I'm 21,
73 is a long time away,
I'm a mortal.
I'm never going to suffer from these
realities,
right?
So I can easily discount that
information.
But tell me,
show me vividly that I might not be able
to perform with my really hot
girlfriend.
Well,
it doesn't take much of an evolutionary
psychologist to understand that people
will respond to this.
Just to draw another parallel from the
women's part.
Women turn out to be the ones who are
overwhelmingly most likely to expose
themselves to the sun,
whether either the actual natural sun or
artificial sunbeds,
even though they're much more
knowledgeable than men about the effects
of sun exposure.
So it's not because they didn't know any
better than they were doing the behavior
because they know more than men and yet
they do it more so they do it more
because of an aesthetic reason,
because they think that they're going to
get that health glow.
I'm going to be at tonight's party,
Tony's going to be there and I need to
look good for Tony.
So if you simply tell them that when
you're going to be 74,
you might suffer a greater incidence of
melanoma.
Who Cares?
On the other hand,
if you show them aesthetic ravages to
your skin,
that increases their attention to your
message.
So the bottom line is learn what are the
evolutionary triggers that get people's
attention and use that rather than
simply provide them with more
information.
So that is one applied the reality of
this approach.
What are the evolutionary triggers that
cause people to smoke in the first
place?
Well,
I don't think that's necessarily an
evolutionary trait.
I think it's just because tobacco is,
I mean is addictive,
right?
And so,
but that doesn't explain the initial
first time,
start smoking the first time you smoke.
It's disgusting.
Yet what I saw,
I'm going to.
I'm going off the cuff here.
So I don't know because I haven't
thought about that exact question.
It turns out as you probably know,
that if you don't start smoking by the
age of 19,
I don't know why the number 19,
maybe it's because it's the teenage
years.
You're almost guaranteed to never smoke.
Right?
So.
So the tobacco companies really have to
get you when you're a kid.
I know a guy who started when he was 14,
actually.
I'm like,
Mike,
I have a cousin who started at 33 so
that they are anomalies.
That's so crazy,
isn't it?
So my feeling is it's probably a form.
So if I'm going to link it in some way
to an evolutionary mechanism,
it's probably just pure conformity,
right?
To the extent that that young kids think
that the school to smoke,
they were just going to imitate others.
What do you think?
Um,
I think they want to look cool.
They see that character that's smoking
and just takes that big deep drag in
that exhale and they're slipping a
rebel.
They don't even give a fuck about their
health.
Looking at them out there just smoking
cigarettes.
Right.
Probably wearing leather,
looking like a crazy person.
Do you know what?
I've never taken a single puff of my
entire life.
Congratulations.
Have you?
Fuck you.
I'm not talking about drugs.
Just
smoking.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
I've,
uh,
I smoked a cigarette when I was 15.
I didn't like it.
I quit my sister,
stuck with it for a long time.
We did it together.
I was 15,
she was 14.
She smoked for a long time after that.
So why did you see the first time?
Um,
I would have to go back to the time when
I was 15 and asked myself.
I probably just wanted to try it.
I thought it was cool.
It was the adult thing.
We did a lot of adult things that were
gross,
like we tried liquor and like,
you know,
there's a lot of things that we did that
you were supposed to do because it was
supposed to be like a cool person thing,
but it's gross.
Um,
I've done it since then before shows
because I have friends that were smokers
and uh,
I had read that there's a nootropic
benefit to nicotine and that one of the
things that Steven King said when he
wrote his book on writing,
um,
one of the more.
It's a great book by the way,
on writing if anybody's interested in
writing,
but coming from a real master,
a guy who's been incredibly prolific,
but his attitude and his philosophy on
writing is pretty unique.
Um,
but one of the things that he said that
he struggled after he quit smoking
because of the synaptic,
the,
the synaptic benefit,
the cognitive benefits of smoking was
really beneficial for his writing.
It like really fired up his writing.
And so a couple of times back when my
friend Tony Hinchcliffe,
he quit recently quit like a,
about a year or so ago.
Uh,
but he would smoke and I,
and a couple of times he would be
smoking before a show.
It's a give me one of those things.
We try that I have no fear at all,
that I would ever be addicted to
cigarettes.
I have zero fear.
It's not possible.
There's no way in my mindset that I
would ever allow myself to be physically
addicted,
but using it as a tool right before I
went onstage,
I've found it to give me a little bit of
a charge.
I was like,
it's kind of interesting,
not valuable enough for me to pursue and
not necessarily even better than other
nootropics or other cognitive enhancing
things like coffee or,
you know,
for me the real one is breathing and
moving around.
I just like to get my blood pumping and
take some big deep breaths and fire my
brain up and get my,
like,
like here,
we already,
I had a cup of coffee earlier.
But the stimulation of actual dialog of
talking to somebody and talking to an
intelligent,
beautiful personally yourself,
aren't you lucky this is a,
it's exciting.
It gets you fired up and it gets all the
cylinders pumping.
Um,
but there is something to cigarettes.
There's definitely something I've
founded,
a stimulated.
What is it that made you feel so
confident that you would not fall prey
to it's addictive properties?
Why do you think that?
I am confident that I'm not a loser
period.
I'm not doing anything stupid with my
body.
I don't,
I don't.
I'm not doing that.
But you don't think that not trying
could over overwhelm your willpower.
Impossible doesn't exist.
There's no door.
You're not getting in La,
it's not,
there's no fucking way I'm going to get
addicted to cigarettes and people
like,
Yo,
man,
you see the openness to shut up,
buzzy.
It's not happening.
So you could call somebody,
push you,
but I can't call them the r word.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
That's how it works.
The double standards.
Well,
pussies also good.
That's the problem with pussy is
ridiculous as a,
as an insult because it's one of the
most wonderful things the world has ever
seen at speaking of policies.
Did you see?
My.
Probably not,
but I put out a sad truth clip where I,
um,
regrettably apologize to the Trans
community because it turns out that I
didn't know that my marriage was
transphobic.
Do you know why your marriage is
transphobic?
Yes.
Because some trans activists have argued
that it is ridiculous for heterosexual
men to strictly want to mate because
when we're talking about pussies,
so strictly want to mate with women who
have pussies when there are some women
who have nine inch penises that are just
as much of a women.
Uh,
and I argued that now that I've learned
this,
it's ridiculous that I focused on
building a life as a heterosexual man
with a woman that has a vagina and not
with a woman that has a nine inch penis.
And therefore,
I apologize for my transphobia.
Well,
that doesn't make any sense because
shouldn't it be just like with the fat
thing that you just just choose whatever
and then be happy with what you got that
there's no discrimination at all.
You just managed to fall in love.
You just got lucky and it's an actual
lots of vagina male,
a woman who has a vagina that's not
surgically created.
But had I been more progressive and open
to the early now,
did you ever date a trans person?
No.
So there you go.
You don't have to date a bunch of people
like that.
You know,
like to say that you've never dated
anybody who's over six foot five.
Well,
you're tall phobic.
That's a ridiculous statement.
That doesn't make any sense.
You know,
to say that you've,
uh,
you've never dated anybody that weighs
more than 300 pounds.
You,
you know,
you're a,
you're a mass phobic.
That's ridiculous.
Yeah.
It's just all of it's stupid.
It's stupid people telling,
but this,
what they're doing is it's a bunch of
people that are pushing this idea of
being open entirely open to all things
trans that you as a heterosexual person
should not just recognize that this is a
woman because they transferred from a
male to a female,
but recognize even if they haven't
transferred and recognize them in terms
of sexual selection in terms of a date.
Right.
And that's just fucking stupid because
you can decide,
right?
You're not into certain things.
Like I'm not really into girls with
short hair.
You could decide that it's not my thing.
I don't like girls with shaved heads.
I don't find it attractive.
Like a woman can say that too.
I don't like guys have creepy mustaches
and nobody gets mad at him.
But if a man says to certain people,
I'm not into chicks with Dicks,
then that guy's a piece of shit.
Or what about,
there's a thing called sexual racism
where you specifically,
you know,
are not attracted to a particular.
You know,
I don't like
Asian men,
I don't like black women.
Right.
You're not supposed to instantiate those
sexual preferences.
If the racial q is the one that's
causing you to either be attracted or
not attached to someone,
what do you think of that?
Um,
well there's certainly beautiful people
of all race,
so that doesn't make a whole lot of
sense to me in terms of the person
selection.
Like if you tell them you've never seen
a beautiful black woman,
right?
Like you're crazy.
Like you have met enough black women.
If you tell me 17,
a beautiful Asian woman,
like what,
what are you saying?
Like there's beautiful people in this
also,
you should be allowed to be with whoever
you want in terms of.
But why is it it's always sex,
right?
Because like obnoxious people.
Here's a perfect example.
I don't like friends that are loud and
get drunk in public.
Oh,
what are you drunk phobic?
No,
I just don't enjoy that.
So like in terms of sexual selection,
the dates,
I'll tell you why that analogy might
fail.
Okay.
Tell me the progressive's you could
alter your level of obnoxiousness.
You could grow out of your boxes as
well.
I know some people,
conceivably,
theoretically we're fucked.
That's just who they are.
Fair enough.
If you want to name any names,
no,
but your race is a immutable part of
you.
Okay.
That's the perspective.
I see that I'm playing devil's advocate.
I'm not agreeing with it.
Okay.
Well,
what about a tall versus short?
Right?
You know what,
if you're a woman volleyball player and
you're six foot three and you don't want
to date a guy was five feet tall,
you know,
are you.
What are you,
what are you?
By the way,
that is one of the biggest problems with
being a very tall woman because one of
the,
one of the.
So there's something called assorted of
mating and evolutionary theory sort of
meeting is basically birds of a feather
flock together and that's very much the
mechanism that drives may choice much
more than opposites attract.
So one of the sources of mating cues
that people most sword on his height,
so it's not so much that women want guys
that are only six foot or taller,
it's just that the woman wants a guy
who's taller than her.
So if you look at the,
there is a study that I've discussed in
the past that looked at something like
720 actual couples and I think there was
only a single one out of the 720 where
the woman was taller than the man.
Now once a woman gets to be over a
certain height,
she's six foot two,
six foot three.
Her potential pool of prospective
suitors really shrinks.
And so if you have a daughter,
you really want to pray that she doesn't
get too tall because boy are her choices
is going to be limited because few women
want to date the shorter guy than them.
Yeah.
When you're a six foot three,
six foot four woman,
you're got to be a tough spot.
But you're basically relegated to big
athletes are big giant people.
The,
the,
the other place where you get this sort
of assorted of mating is where you get
women who are super educated,
uh,
that makes sense.
The exact same thing happened.
The more educated a woman gets,
the worse her marriage prospects because
the more sophisticated women are,
the more they insist on a high status
male.
And therefore,
as I get more educated as a woman,
there are just fewer men who are as
educated or more than me and therefore
I'm doomed to a life of solitude.
That totally makes sense.
Especially considering that men in
general,
they get insecure around women who are
more successful and more educated or
more intelligent.
Like very rarely are men comfortable
with a woman who has to explain things
to them.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
By the way,
I think.
So I have another theory which I'd like
to at some point test.
Maybe someone will steal it now.
So when you have a couple that gets
married very young,
they are judging one another based on
their mate value at 18 or 19.
Right.
So Tony is the high school quarterback
and so he's the hot guy and I'm the
cheerleader and then later he stagnates.
He doesn't go on with his career.
Whereas I go on and become a physician.
I am a cheerleader,
so I 29.
There is not a huge inequity between our
two mating values on the meeting market.
Right.
So when we were both 19,
the fact that we had roughly the same
thing,
value made us a very attractive,
stable couple,
but tony turned out to be a fucking
loser.
Exactly.
He's a lame duck.
And so I.
So I have a theory that and I'd like to
at some point tested,
maybe some graduate student will write
to me saying,
I'll work with this on you,
Dr.
Sad.
I have a theory whereby I think that in
many cases where people end up divorcing
when they married young,
it's precisely because that which
started as equitable mating values at
time t zero turned out to have huge
divergence in our trajectory on the
meeting market.
And that puts a huge strain on the
marriage,
especially when the wife status is going
up,
that the best way to ensure that the
marriage ends is for the status of the
woman to keep going up and that the man
to either stagnate or go down,
that's going to be doomed.
That makes sense.
It makes sense that also,
you know,
obviously the young marriages are rough
because people grow and they don't
necessarily grow together when you catch
people 10 years later and they're
oftentimes radically different people.
Right.
But then there's also the thing that
women don't seem to,
for the most part,
respect a man who's not doing as well as
them.
Right.
You know,
that's a,
that's a giant issue.
Even if the is doing okay,
like say if your guys making $50,000
a year,
that's a very good living.
He's out there doing well but you make
300,
maybe 300 grand a year and it's fucking
losers over here.
What is 50 grand like you're kicking
ass,
you know,
like some big wig at some big
corporation like that.
That seems to be a real sticking point.
And with men,
especially if they have a household
where they contributed income together,
they pile all the income and the man
starts spending the woman's money on
stuff.
You know,
he starts buying stuff.
You got a new fishing rod and did you
get
that with your money or my money,
you know,
it gets weird,
right?
And incidentally,
speaking of say,
consumer psychology stuff that I study,
when you take a very rich woman and you
go out on a date with her,
even though she obviously can afford the
dinner and she can afford anything that
you're going to buy her,
if you exhibit cues of frugality,
cheapness,
that's the perfect way to ensure that
you won't have a second date.
So it's not so much a question of,
uh,
you know,
it's an old sexist,
the ritual whereby men were wooing
women.
It really is an honest signal of your
commitment to,
to a woman.
So the best way,
and I get many of these letters where
people asked me,
hey professor,
what are,
you know,
dating advice.
Well,
you do have to exhibit generosity when
you go out with that,
the nuptial gift giving,
natural gift giving.
Is it sort of a fancy term for courtship
rituals across animal species?
So many species you have typically the
male engaging in some form of courtship,
gift giving,
and depending on the quality of the
gift,
will determine whether the female will
mate with your not well.
So much of what we do in marketing
context is exactly that,
right?
It's the exact same phenomenon repeating
itself in the human context,
right?
Uh,
engagement rings,
right?
The fact that you are supposed to spend
a quarter of your yearly salary on this
rock,
I really what it is.
That's what I'm.
I don't know if everybody meets it,
but that's right.
It is that right?
It's three months,
exact God.
When you say a quarter of the yearly
salary,
it makes you just go,
what the fuck is wrong with people,
but the reason so much money,
but here's the,
but here's the reason.
Here's the reason you ready?
It's what's called a hobby and signal.
I don't know if I've ever discussed this
in this,
in this podcast is a hobby and signal is
basically the idea that for a signal,
to be honest,
it has to be costly,
otherwise everybody could imitate it.
Right?
So,
so,
so think about,
for example,
rites of passage in different cultures,
right?
If you want to demonstrate that you're a
top warrior,
the rite of passage has to be brutal.
Otherwise,
if it's only,
we all have to do five setups than every
male could do it.
And then the females can determine the
pretenders from the real guys.
Right?
So,
so you have,
for example,
a bullet ant,
you know this one too,
right?
You put your hands through.
I mean that takes a lot of courage and
capacity to people who don't know what
you're talking about.
So this is a tribe in the Amazon whereby
you take the bullet,
ant is supposedly the,
the biggest purveyor of pain that is
humanly possible that you could
experience.
My friend Steve gets done by one,
did it,
and what did.
He was in Bolivia,
I believe.
And uh,
he got stung and in his heel got them in
the heel and he said it was just,
he was delirious.
Exactly,
exactly.
Said it lasts for a few hours,
then it goes away,
right?
So what they do in this tribe is they
take a bunch of these ants in the order
of a couple of 100.
One is enough to cause agonizing,
impossible,
delirious pain,
and they said date them through this
compound a and then they enter,
weave them in these gloves,
these a leaf gloves so that when they're
coming to,
they come out of their stupor and you
have your hands in there,
they start viciously biting you,
stinging you,
and you're supposed to withstand that
pain without screaming.
You have to take it.
And so you sort of almost go onto this
religious fervor,
this kind of an incantation,
and you have to do that ritual 20
separate occasions at different times on
different days,
20 slash 20 before you are admitted into
the tribe of Warriors,
whatever.
Well now let's think back to the
engagement ring,
right?
If all it takes for me to convince you
of my honest intentions is to buy you
flowers and now let's go back behind the
shed and you know,
have sex,
well then a lot of cheaters are going to
convince you of doing this one.
They really didn't have good intentions,
but if it takes for me to spend a
quarter of my salary to convince you
that I have honestly,
so therefore this is a form of what's
called is a hobby and signaling because
it's a hobby,
was a Israeli ornithologist that studied
this type of behavior,
this costly signaling behavior using
Arabian babblers,
which is a type of bird.
So here's another example of as a hobby
having signal,
you probably have seen this when you
have a Predator that's looking at who to
attack,
you often will have gazelles starting to
actually make themselves conspicuously
visible to the Predator.
They come close to them and they start
jumping from,
have you ever seen this student?
I think it's called stroking,
not strutting.
And can you think why that would be
like,
why are they not hiding?
Why are they not making themselves a
inconspicuously?
Why are they drawing attention to
themselves when they are 50 different
gazelles that the Predator could be
pointing to?
Why?
Well,
because what what,
what that animal is saying is the fact
that I could stand here in front of you
and jump up and down and make myself
this visible suggests that it's probably
a lost cause for you to try to go after
me.
I'm Super Fit,
right?
It's a costly signal of my fitness.
It's an honest signal,
right?
The one who is not doing this behavior
is the one that you should be paying
attention to interest.
So this is called and so I use this
principle of as a hobby and signaling to
explain things like conspicuous
consumption,
right?
The reason why you buy the fancy car
that the other males can't hope to
purchase,
it's precisely because they can't afford
to match your signal.
Therefore it's an honest signal.
The reason why I buy 100 million dollar
painting that a monkey could have drawn
shows how wealthy I am,
that I could waste $100,
million dollars.
Oh,
that makes sense.
That makes sense.
It's all just meeting stuff.
It's mating and food.
You don't want to become somebody
dinner.
You want to find dinner and you want to
have sex.
Goodnight everybody.
Yeah.
Those signals are so fascinating.
When we see them in our culture and
people get angry at them,
like you see some guy pull up in a
Ferrari and you go look at this fucking
loser with those little Duke,
right?
You're like maybe.
Or maybe a guy with a shitload of money
wants to let the world know because he
likes to fuck you.
Right.
I've shared actually on this show,
I think the stories about my.
One of my brothers who was a big car
collector,
three Ferrari's,
Aston Martin Lagonda,
and I've even shared a story which I'm
happy to repeat of.
We would go to nightclubs where he's
this,
this is the Olympian,
this is the five foot three guy,
go to nightclubs and he would pick the
most beautiful woman and approach her
even though she's accompanied by six
foot four,
you know,
tough fucking guy.
And he had that confidence.
I think because he had that wealth
catapulting him.
He
certainly helps.
It certainly helps.
Yeah,
it's um,
it,
it is a weird ever prevalent aspect in
the communication between men and
females is how much money does the man
have,
right.
I mean,
and this is one thing that a lot of
women hate because they don't want to
feel like they can be purchased and they
can't,
they can't,
some can write a lot can.
It's a factor.
It's a big and a lot of women are very
just rabidly ruthlessly independent.
They don't want that ever in their life
and good for them.
But,
but the reality is that's a very
effective strategy.
You pull up in that Ferrari or that
Rolls Royce or whatever the fuck you're
driving and it,
it has a big impact and you get to that
nightclub and those studies have been
done endlessly and psychology.
So here's one example,
and you don't need to have a signal as
big as a Ferrari,
just how you dress in terms of the
status that is exhibited.
So there's a study that was done,
I think in the early nineties where they
manipulated the status,
the sartorial,
the,
the attire of men and women into one of
three different types,
you know,
high status,
medium and know some tee shirt or a
McDonald's uniform,
whatever.
And then they asked men and women,
uh,
one of six possible,
you know,
would you go out for coffee with this
guy when you go out on dinner,
would you have sex with him?
Would you marry him?
And across all six levels of
relationships,
the status of the attire of a man had a
profound effect on the likelihood of the
woman saying yes,
higher status,
the more likely she said yes.
That same manipulation on women had zero
effect on men.
In other words,
no man has ever uttered the following
words,
my God,
you've got a but,
and I'd love to have sex with you,
but you're not exhibiting cues of
ambition,
therefore no sex for you,
Linda.
Yeah.
So that's a reality.
That's a reality that people are very
uncomfortable with.
And I don't think women necessarily are
craving the same reaction from men
because of their ambition.
I don't think women are ever saying
through my ambition,
I'm going to get a good man.
Right?
You know,
just,
just not a factor.
But they do say through my ambition,
I'm never going to need a map.
True.
That's because that's just.
Look,
the reality is there's a lot of shitty
human beings out there and some of them
have penises and if you're a woman and
you run into too many of those or for
buy for whatever reason,
because of your environment,
because of your behavior,
because of the circles,
you travel in your around too many of
them,
a large dating pool of shitheads out
there.
You know,
you just say,
I don't want this in my life.
I want.
I don't want to be like my mom.
I don't want to be like my sister.
I want to be independent.
But what you're not saying is I am going
to get a bar house and a baller car and
I'm going to get me a man.
And the only woman that I know of that
I've ever heard say that is disgusting.
And the only woman that I ever,
she's like,
you know,
talking about her success and our
success allows her to get men.
She's a foul beast.
Wow.
Yeah.
She's not.
It's not healthy.
A lot of women,
it's not so much that they're
interesting.
I mean resources are good only to the
extent that they allow you to ascend the
social hierarchy,
right?
This,
this doesn't explain why some women are
attracted to the starving artists,
right?
Because why are so many women
romanticizing over the guy with the
guitar.
But that's because they are choosing him
based on his future trajectory.
Right?
I am back.
I am banking on the fact that you
exhibit enough talent that I suspect
that by investing in you,
by choosing you,
it's going to take me to that
trajectory.
No woman has ever uttered the following
words.
You have no talent.
You exhibit no ambition.
You're never going to step out of the
basement.
Let's have sex.
And you know,
so.
So it's not that women are only
interested in money.
They're interested in a panoply of cues,
all of which relate to the potential of
ascending the social hierarchy.
Yeah,
that makes sense,
but it makes sense that these things are
biologically interwoven into our psyche.
No kidding.
It makes sense.
I mean,
it just.
It.
It's unavoidable.
Well,
that's.
That's why I'm always on.
I think the first time that I came on
this show,
we discussed this.
I'm always amazed that so many people
have such antipathy towards evolutionary
psychology because there is really no
other game in town.
I mean it.
What else could explain the evolution of
the most important organ that defines
our person had called the human mind,
right?
I mean,
you're comfortable accepting that the
liver and the kidneys and the heart has
evolved through evolution,
but you can't accept that your mind and
your brain has evolved through
evolution,
so it's really.
It's an form
insane form of science denialism that
I've spent 25 years fighting and I'm not
sure if I'm any closer to winning the
battle.
It's the only form of science denialism.
It's culturally acceptable.
It's culturally acceptable because it
defines people in a way that makes them
feel like animals or makes them feel
cheap or it makes them feel like they're
prostitutes.
You know?
It makes it,
makes people feel like they're
prostitutes,
and interestingly,
it comes a lot more for this particular
form of science than eyes and from the
left.
This is why a lot of a lot of people
will write me and say,
well,
why do you seem to be critiquing a lot
more people on the left and the right?
That's not.
That's not showing my political colors.
It's simply because the ecosystem that I
navigate in,
which is called academia,
it just so happens that most of the bs
comes from the left because the academia
is laden with leftists,
so it's not so much that I give a free
pass to the right.
When you have a right wing senator who
denies evolution,
I'm the first to also critique him,
but the reality is when it comes to
human nature,
it's really the leftists who are denying
the biological basis of our human
nature.
Why do you think that this science
denialism is so prevalent on the last,
on the left when it comes to gender?
Because gender seems to be the
battleground.
It seems to be the battle ground even in
terms of transgender,
right?
Uh,
but the,
the battleground of gender,
whether it's the gender pay gap or
whether it's traditional gender roles,
this seems to be where science denialism
lives on the left in the more,
you know,
like what I always grew up thinking
about the left,
the left was always more open minded.
They were supposed to be the more
educated and they were supposed to be
more compassionate people.
So something happened and I don't know
when it happened,
but somewhere along the line,
this science denialism and this,
for whatever reason,
this idea that if it shows any
differences,
if there's any statistics or any data
that shows differences between the men
and the women,
that this is somehow.
This is somehow an example of sexism or
patriarchal tyranny or there's a reason
for this that's negative.
So I think the reason is actually quite,
quite simple.
At the right wing folks who deny
science,
it's typically for religious ideological
reasons for industry,
right?
So,
so there is some pet ideology that is
threatening me and therefore I'm going
to deny science this exact same thing
happening with the left.
They also have been parametize a quasi
religion.
It's called progressivism.
Okay.
And I say progressivism in quotes,
right?
Uh,
you know,
equality of outcomes and all the rest of
the garbage,
right?
And therefore to the extent that
evolutionary theory in general,
but evolutionary psychology in
particular is a threat to my quasi
religion than I will reject
it.
This is why evolution deniers tend to be
on the right and evolution psychology
that iris than to be on the left.
They've both been parasitized by
religions.
They're just different religions.
That's so,
that's a fast anyway to look at it,
that progressivism is in fact some sort
of religion and it makes sense if you're
looking at the science denialism aspect
of it because you're not looking at it
in terms of an objective analysis of all
the facts and the data that's in front
of you.
You're saying what fits this construct,
what fits this pattern of behavior that
I've chosen to adopt,
and then I have to show all the people
that are around me like you accused Sean
Carroll of doing,
adopting this instead of looking at the
actual facts of this case.
Postmodernism,
I think.
Did you have.
You had the grievance studies focused on
the right.
Fantastic.
I mean Peter,
but goes,
I mean Kim's Lindsey,
could you,
could you believe that?
This is stuff that is repeatedly
wonderful,
right?
That podcast.
If you haven't heard it,
folks,
please listen to it.
These guys and a Gal with the woman from
Helen Blank rows,
James Lindsey and Peter Boghossian.
Yeah.
People goes to you and James Lindsey
with the one we're here.
Uh,
the woman Helen lives in England.
Yes.
And they came on the podcast and they
talked about all these different false
studies and false papers that they
published that were peer reviewed and
published in academic journals that like
things like what was the one
heteronormativity in dog parks.
Yeah.
So,
so the,
the humping.
And I tell you a quick funny story
phobia and dog parks.
So I'll,
I'll,
I'll say this,
a few folks knew about this project
before it came out.
One of them has a name that sounds like
glaad slide.
Oh,
I didn't know that guy.
He's just glad.
Father,
he's the godfather now.
It turns out that I didn't know the
which,
which particular studies they were
sending out.
I knew about the general project,
but I didn't know the details and so I
wanted this project go on for,
I think it was maybe 18 months if I'm
not mistaken,
something that order.
Well,
at one point I was flipping through
something,
whatever,
and I saw the dog rape culture stuff
new.
So I contact feet.
I go,
I just,
there was no even sanitation,
there wasn't.
Hi,
how are you?
I go dog park rape you.
So he calls me up like within a few
seconds he's just cracking up laughing.
That's the background to some of these
stories.
He was up for some sort of disciplinary
review right after he left the podcast
with me.
I don't know how that went or what went.
A lot of people are gunning for him.
Yeah,
he was.
He was explaining that,
but I think what he's doing is very
valuable and I think that it needs to be
known and especially in terms of like
people listening to this,
they're going to send their kids to
these fucking schools and spend $50,000
a year.
This is why,
by the way,
people,
often times people write to me.
Even even my wife was telling me,
well,
why do you care so much about this?
Is it because imagine all of these
people,
they're spending their parents hard
earned money.
They could have been studying tons of
really interesting,
true things and I don't mean true.
It has to be scientific.
You could study art and you could study
literature.
You could study philosophy,
so I'm not.
I'm not creating a hierarchy of
knowledge.
It's all good,
but as long as you are committed to
reason to logic and so on,
these fields are what I call
intellectual terrorism.
They're nihilists and it pisses me off
as a professor that they've been allowed
to promulgate for 40,
50 years,
untouched.
And so those who argue that these guys
were frauds because they,
they,
you know,
they submitted these papers under a
pseudonym.
Well,
what did you expect them to do?
I mean,
if,
if you're a whistleblower,
do you not submit your complaint or
using the name Jane Doe?
So the fact that they use a pseudonym
that's hardly fraudulent.
If you're going to demonstrate how
fraudulent that whole enterprise is.
So what if you use the false name and
what do you think?
Don't you agree?
Oh,
100 percent.
Yeah,
it's,
it's important.
It's important to expose this idiocy
because it's so prevalent and it's so
ridiculous and there's a bunch of fake
intellectuals out there that are
repeating all this nonsense and so when
they see this and what's should be
almost like onion level satire,
obvious and they don't think so.
And they rewarded and they,
they talk about it's one of the best
papers they've read this year because
these people are preposterous and this
is just one of those things where you
let people get away with things and then
they keep pushing it,
keep pushing it,
it goes further.
They keep getting further with it and
eventually they just get away.
They're too far gone.
You can't bring them back.
I actually told Pete and I hope I don't
think he'll mind that I'm sharing this,
but when,
when he was telling me about the
project,
one of the things that I try to temper
or his expectations of how much of a
fatal blow the project would be,
he I had the feeling that he was
thinking that if we are successful,
it's the end of the bullshit,
the bullshit edifices and I kept saying,
look,
I think it's really important what
you're doing,
and of course I supported in any way
that I can help and advise you and so
on.
I'm there for you,
but I don't think you should think that
it's going to end and I think I've been
proven to be right because you're 100
percent right,
because I think postmodernism by its
very definition is almost like a snake
that can't be killed.
Right.
Who are you to judge what is bullshit or
not exactly.
I mean,
what percentage of an impact do you
think it had?
Do you think it killed one percent of
the bullshit?
Maybe a bit more.
Two.
I can't put a number,
but I certainly five.
Let's be generous.
Let's go with five.
By the way,
I've spoken to,
you know Alan.
So the original Ho,
do you know the,
the history of this type of hoaxing?
No.
So the original hoax was done by Allen
Soko,
s o k a l who is a physicist who in 1996
submitted a paper.
He's so,
he's a physicist,
so he's,
you know,
hardcore scientists.
And he was,
he was so pissed off and all these post
modernists that he submitted a paper on
the Hermeneutics of gravity,
all this kind of bs and they of course
lapped it up because here's a physicist
who's now joining the Pantheon of our
bullshit,
therefore let's accept it.
And then of course at that point he
said,
oh,
I have something to admit to you guys
now.
Him and I had communicated at one point
I had written an article about his hoax
and he corrected me.
It was very,
very cute because I said,
you know,
this guy created some pseudo random
bullshit,
and he said,
well,
you know,
professor side,
I actually spent quite a bit of effort
coming up with all these words,
so it wasn't random bs.
It was very well thought out vs.
so this is a guy that you might want to
have on.
I don't know if he doesn't any these
pockets,
but he's the,
he's the godfather of hoaxing.
This stuff.
It's just got to be so frustrating to be
in academia and to see all this around
you and see all these false thinkers,
these fake people putting this con game
in the middle of a real learning
institution and not only that but this
being celebrated by other true academics
because they don't want to get called
out as being racist or homophobic or
transphobic or whatever the fuck it is.
These morons are celebrating this.
This is a weird trickery to me.
It's almost like being a comedian and
being around joke thieves,
right?
It's like almost the same thing.
I know you're not the same thing as me.
You're a faker.
You're faking this thing,
we're in this artist's colony.
Everybody else is struggling to come up
with material and you're just stealing
it,
and this is what is going on with these
gender studies.
People like you're pretending you're an
intellectual.
So this is craziness.
You're,
you're,
you're ignoring the science.
So I have a theory.
So the original postmodernists were all
French postmodernist.
I don't know if you know their name,
but for your viewers to Michelle Fuco,
Jacques Lacan and Jacques Derrida,
the three grand bullshitters.
Okay.
And so I have here,
was this the seventies?
This is started about the sixties and
seventies really went into full
throttle.
Right?
Now I,
I'm going to link this back to mating.
Remember we said everything.
Okay?
Now,
I genuinely think that in the deep
recesses of their minds,
these three fraudsters that not believe
a single thing and what they were doing,
but they quickly learned that if they
stood in front of a crowd uttered some
full profundity jibberish and you had
all the hot,
beautiful young ladies sitting and
looking at you as if you a deep poet,
they quickly learned that there's
evolutionary rewards that come with
their full profundity and so the train
was off and they weren't going to get
off the station and then that's it.
The trajectory set.
I truly believe
that if we could ever find some diary or
something of these rounds there,
they probably have written my God that I
get a lot of women.
I guess Michelle for core was gay.
Maybe a lot of young men through my
trickery.
In other words,
I think they admitted it that openly.
No,
I don't even in a diary.
I doubt they admitted it to themselves
that openly,
but so.
Do you think that in the deep recesses
of their mind when they went to bed,
do you think that they've convinced
themselves that they are saying
something profound or they know.
I know they're locked into.
I think this is what I think when most
people are engaging in that sort of
deceptive behavior,
they're locked into a pattern that they
know is effective.
That pattern has some sort of an effect
of a beneficial effect on them,
whether it's sexually,
whether it's in terms of the social
dynamics that they exist in.
There's this pattern.
They've found this pattern that they can
pursue.
That's what I believe,
so therefore they are being self
deceptive to the point where they
believe their bullshit.
Well maybe maybe not even being self
deceptive,
but certainly not being self analytical.
They've,
they've,
they've hit this hot spot where they,
you know,
they lock in and then they just follow
what's effective and what's working.
Yeah.
Perhaps you.
Right.
That's what I do think though,
that eventually all of these guys will
die out.
No.
So you think the BS,
we'll just find a new way,
will metamorphosize into some new
instantiation,
but it's always,
there's always going to be a critical
mass of bs in the university.
I think there's always going to be a
bunch of people that want to believe in
things that are not true because that
makes them seem better than what they
really are.
There's a bunch.
There's always going to be a bunch of
people that want to avoid the reality of
essentially lives unfair,
a ladder system of competition.
There's just.
It's just unfair.
It was just.
A lot of it is just like the natural,
the natural world.
Nature itself is unfair.
Just in general,
you know that the salmon never gets to
eat the eagle.
It's just not fair.
And I think there's a lot of people that
find these inequalities and find this
unfairness very disconcerting.
It disturbs them to no end and they set
out on a quest to try to more the world
and to some weird utopian fantasy land
where everything has an equal outcome.
It doesn't exist.
But in people that are fucked,
you know,
you get people that look like Lena
Dunham and they want to like sort of
like balance out the playing field.
This is like,
it's not fair,
right?
It's like how come Scarlett Johansson is
a woman and how come Lena Dunham is a
woman?
Like what the fuck?
Like that's not fair,
right?
It's not,
it's.
There's a lot of things that aren't
fair.
There's a lot of things that aren't fair
intellectually the way people's minds
function.
They're not this.
There's people that are Ilan mosque and
then there's a other folks,
right?
We just not that bright and this is just
the way the world.
So do you think as as fighters for
reason,
our objective is to simply make sure
that the number of bullshitters stays
below certain thresholds since we can't
eradicate them fully according to your
view,
at least what we could do is sort of
steady the tides so that they're always
below a certain number.
In other words,
10 percent of people are going to be
bullshitters in the university and as
long as they don't get past that
threshold,
we're doing a good job.
Whereas I'd like to be more optimistic.
I'd like to eradicate all of the
bullshitters.
I don't think that's possible,
but I think that bullshit as a whole is
very attractive to people and it's very
attractive to people to pursue.
It's very attractive to people to engage
in a,
they don't like reality and they want to
change things.
There's a lot of bullshit that does
exist in our culture and it has forever.
Why the Fucker chiropractor still
around?
Why are psychic still around right?
Like there's a lot of nonsense out
there.
And then when you look into what those,
what,
what real evidence there is that
psychics are real,
it's almost zero.
Well,
and I could link it by the way to
marketing.
So,
uh,
the dove,
the Dove Company,
they're probably their most successful
campaign of all time has been one where
they argued that beauty is a social
construct.
You're all beautiful in your own way.
Now that again is a beautiful message,
right?
Because if am someone,
if I'm a woman who doesn't score well on
the typical evolutionary cues,
then what do I want to hear?
I want to hear that there is no such
thing as evolutionary accused.
It's all socially constructed,
right?
If I have sagging breast,
if I have poor skin and so on,
if I have wrinkly skin,
I'd like to believe that there is no
such thing as an universal beauty
standards,
and in that sense dove has been
incredibly successful because by
peddling false hope,
they've actually been able to tap into
women's insecurities and incense.
That's good marketing,
right?
Did you see the cover of Cosmopolitan
magazine that was widely criticized
because they had a morbidly obese woman
on who was a bikini plus size model?
Yeah.
Yeah,
and they were challenging beauty norms
like this is a person that's eating
themselves to death.
You've got fucking assholes and so your
lack of discipline and your desire to
shame people who exercise and is what
you're doing to make them feel bad
because you feel bad that you can't put
the fucking cook cookies and cupcakes
down as a lead you to try to push this
ridiculous standard and one of the
things my point of view was,
could you imagine if the cover of men's
health had an enormous fat guy with his
gut hangover,
his belt,
and and people were saying the new
standards of attractiveness for men have
been changed by Mike who just drinks
beer and eats cake.
You'd be like,
get the fuck Outta here.
That's never going to fly.
It's not going to fly with men,
but it does fly with women and by the
way they go.
The Fat Acceptance Movement doesn't just
argue that you know not being 500 pounds
is unattractive because of the
patriarchy.
They actually argue that the medical
evidence suggesting that there is a link
between obesity and downstream
bad effects is all bullshit.
They're not,
not just that they.
They also point to one incredibly flawed
study that has been wildly disproven
that says that there's some sort of
vigor or vitality involved in being
overweight because they they get sick
less.
There's no,
no truth to that whatsoever.
They only,
they only analyze people who were
healthy at the time,
like it's there's.
You can go and Google the study and find
out the criticism of that study,
but it's 100 percent horseshit folks
being fat's not good for you.
It's really bad for you when you're as
big as that woman on the cover of
Cosmopolitan magazine.
She's literally morbidly obese.
She's fucking dying.
She's addicted to food in a horrible way
and to promote that and pretend that
somehow or another this is okay and
we're going to.
We're going to show new standards of
beauty.
You Go,
you giant gelatinous bag of meat and
tissue.
No,
that's a dying person who's addicted to
food.
She doesn't want to look like that.
I feel as though given that on one of
these shows,
you spend about 45 minutes fat shaming
me,
that they talked to you about your diet.
There hasn't been a recognition of your
slimness much,
much slimmer.
You are.
Slender,
felt a bit of drool coming.
When I first came in,
there was a bit of drool on the side of
your thing when you saw me.
You ridiculous.
No drawer.
I'm happy for you.
Thank you.
There's no drill.
How much weight have you lost?
About 30.
That's nice.
That's very good.
And I have to register as a dangerous
weapon.
Wow.
Thirty more.
Yeah.
You're on the door.
What are you doing different?
Great question.
At being accountable to the scale.
Being accountable to how many things go
in my mouth.
So meaning every Friday,
no matter what I get on the scale,
you see what I'm saying?
So I've put on three pounds,
therefore I intercept that trajectory at
three pounds rather than in four years
when I get on the scale and I'm all 32
pounds overweight.
So number one being a,
you know,
privy to that information.
Secondly,
my wife,
whom you've met many times,
enters all my stuff and my fitness
pal.com.
So at the end of the day,
at the end of the day,
she tells me you've eaten 1,792
calories and you've exercised 400
calories.
You had 1300 calories.
Good.
Now you might say that's not sustainable
to be so sort of Nazi,
like in terms of your accountability for
your whole life.
But for me that really works because I'm
very objective oriented.
If I let it slide,
then I can wake up one day and I'm 30
pounds overweight.
I don't think I've seen you.
Now that I think about.
I'm just trying to show you anything
about your back and you couldn't get on
my machine.
That's what it was.
I don't think we even talked about your
weight.
We did.
We were spending about 40 minutes,
40 minutes.
You.
As a matter of fact,
I remember that.
I know that you don't read your
comments.
I had gone to check some of the comments
that some people were quite upset at
you.
Fat People for no for you that I'll
maybe
get off your ass.
You fat fucks.
Lazy Bitch.
I knew it was coming from.
Was coming from concern and love Cyprus.
I didn't take it badly.
Have you looked at what Jordan Peterson
is doing?
A lot of the meat stuff,
right?
Yeah.
The carnivore diet,
so very fascinating.
He's lost 50 pounds.
He looks amazing.
He said he's at his intellectual peak.
He sees overrunning with energy.
It doesn't take any supplements,
doesn't take anything,
just eats meat.
Wow.
It's astounding.
Do there.
I know that.
Is that sorta the Quito thing,
right?
There's no,
it's not.
It's different because of glucogenesis.
When you have a Quito is more fat than
anything.
It's more fat even than proteins.
He's eating mostly protein and fat,
but much more protein that you would get
an acute agentic diet.
I see,
so he's not necessarily in a state of
ketosis.
I mean we probably have some of the time
when your body has a large quantity of
protein,
your body converts that protein into
glucose into glucogenesis.
It's a very interesting process,
but it's one of the reasons why if you
eat too much protein,
it knocks you out of ketosis because
your body changes.
It turns it into glucose.
What he's doing is essentially an
elimination diet.
He's only eating meat and when I've
talked to like actual real nutrition
experts who really understand the
process,
they do not recommend what he's doing
great,
but I think maybe that's because it
hasn't been done and studied on a wide
scale before.
There have been a few anecdotal reports
about people have eating just meat for
20 years and they're real healthy.
It seems to really be effective with
people that have autoimmune issues.
People that have psoriasis,
people that have various autoimmune
conditions.
It seems that cutting out all
inflammation causing foods,
meaning dairy,
sugar,
all the pasta and bread,
all those things seem to have a profound
effect on certain people.
His daughters,
one of them,
he's one of them and I know some other
people as well.
I know some really smart people that
have gotten into that and they've
experienced profound changes in their
body composition.
They have lost a tremendous amount of
weight.
Even people that are eating a large
amount of meat.
It's not something that's attractive to
me.
First of all,
I think fiber's important.
Phytonutrients that report and there's a
lot of stuff you get from vegetables and
also I don't have a negative reaction to
vegetables doesn't seem to be affecting
me,
but some people I think it's entirely
possible do right and I think if you do
have some really profound autoimmune
issues,
particularly it seems to be effective
with certain types of arthritis.
It's not the worst thing to give a shot.
I would definitely recommend that if you
did do something like that,
that you would supplement and I don't
think Jordan's doing that at all.
I don't think there's any harm
whatsoever in supplementing with
multivitamins,
getting your essential new nutrients,
essential fatty acids from fish oil,
the vitamin B Complex d complex,
make sure you've got all your bases
covered nutritionally and then if your
body just responds really well to only
eating meat,
I'm Jordan,
looks fantastic.
Every time I talk to me it looks better.
I would be curious to know though what
some of his metrics are.
The LDL hdl.
Well,
here's the thing about that,
you know that is very poorly understood
and almost always misinterpreted the ldl
hdl correspondence and what it means in
terms of like whether or not you're
healthy,
arterial plaque is important,
and then there's.
There's all sorts of markers that can
show inflammation,
inflammation in your body,
what your blood pressure is,
how some people react much differently
to the various foods,
right?
We obviously know that some people were
to certain nuts this.
There's the people very biologically,
so much that one of the things that
needs to do nutrition experts are saying
that if you just have your body consumed
just one thing and this elimination
diet,
it eliminates so many different
processes that your body has to engage
in in order to break down all the other
different things and then it eliminates
all the different reactions that you get
from all these various foods.
Your body's only concentrating on one
food all the time and it seems to
alleviate a lot of these conditions.
There's also the fact that when you're
eating just meat,
you're not going to be as hungry.
You're not going to.
You're not going to overeat as much.
It's it's much less likely that you
overeat with protein than it is that you
overeat with pasta breads and sugars and
things along those lines in terms of
caloric intake,
just you,
you hate,
you reach your satiety point very
quickly.
Yes,
and that is probably a factor as well
because Jordan has lost a tremendous
amount of weight and I think in losing
that weight,
his body is less inflamed.
He has less fat that's in inhibiting his
motion and you know his arteries and his
body is.
His limbs aren't as fat.
It's faces on fat.
He's not snoring anymore,
which indicates that he was.
He probably had some fat in his face and
it was kind of blocking and and
constricting his breathing.
It's all really interesting.
There's a gentleman I not sure if I'm
going to get his name right.
He's a nutritional psychiatrist at
Columbia University.
I just discovered it recently while
working out on the elliptical through
the a big thing series and he's got a
couple of short clips where he talks
about how he incorporates nutrition
within his psychiatric practice.
I think his name is drew Ramsay.
He seems like a guy that would be
unplugging so many people.
You probably a few too many buddies
seemed like a a booking agent right now,
but I mean he seems like a really
interesting guy because he shows you.
Here's a psychiatrist who,
who thinks ultimately that a lot of our
mood related issues relate to what we
put in our bodies.
Well,
there's no question that inflammation
has a direct result or a direct action
on how you think and feel.
Inflammation makes people irritated.
It makes people with magic does a lot of
terrible things to just your body in
general,
which affects your brain,
which is a part of your body.
You know the idea that somehow or
another non interchangeable is pretty
preposterous and people that don't take
care of their body but want their brain
to be healthy.
That is like,
you want your cake and you want to eat
it.
Me,
it's like you don't.
You don't make any sense.
You're not looking at it holistically.
So someone who is as passionate as you
are about these issues.
If someone in your family,
whether it be your wife or your
children,
we're not doing the right choices,
does that cause you to be that much more
irate because they're sort of within the
purview of your influence or how do you
steer rebelling?
I would think that maybe I'm being an
overbearing asshole.
I would look at it internally first and
then I would look at them and try to
figure out like what?
What is,
what is?
What's wrong here?
Is this simply a dietary thing or is it
a psychological thing?
It will become a big project for sure.
I mean when there's a loved one that's
essentially eating themselves into poor
health,
which is really common.
It's more common than.
It's not.
In fact,
I think the most recent estimate google
this,
if you will,
young Jamie,
I think the most recent estimate is that
the United States is above 50 percent
obesity rate.
That's incredible.
Which is stunning.
I actually,
when I was at the Canadian Senate
hearings,
actually argued that if we wished to get
rid of bigotry,
then when we'd get a lot more bank for
our buck if we went after fat bigotry
rather than transgender bigotry because
they are so few people who are
transgendered and even though we should
condemn any bigotry they face,
they make up a very small portion that I
was being facetious,
but I was basically arguing that,
look,
if you really want to have these bills
that try to stamp out bigotry,
you should be going after fatphobia
because most Canadians are also obese
now.
They didn't get.
I said it's a sizable problem.
Many obesity United States here goes a
2018 course behavioral risk factors.
Adult obesity raised now exceed 35
percent in seven states.
Yeah.
But what about children as well?
I think they're talking about overall.
I think overall I think children are
more fat now than they've ever been
ever.
Well,
I had a moment.
I mentioned earlier that I had read all
that kids get the actual numbers again.
So the uh,
adult obesity exceeds 35 percent,
30 percent,
29 states,
25 percent in 48 states.
West Virginia has the highest adult
obesity rate,
38 percent,
Colorado lowest at 22.
Shout out to Colorado adult obesity rate
increased in Iowa,
Massachusetts,
Oklahoma,
Rhode Island,
South Carolina.
What is it by,
for not just adult obesity,
but overall obesity.
That's fine.
What is the obesity rate in America?
One hundred and 60 million people.
It is 160 million
people in America are either obese or
overweight.
Nearly three quarters of American men
and more than 60 percent of women,
more than 60 percent of women are
overweight.
Thirty percent of boys
and girls under the age of 20 are obese
or overweight.
So remember I was mentioning earlier,
I was mentioning the a health summit
that I held at my university at one of
the guys.
His name is Robert Lustig.
He's a pediatric endocrinologist.
He was red.
He was saying that many instances of
diabetes and other really high blood
pressure that you would never ever see
in young children is now very,
very common.
So 25,
30 years ago,
he would never have a single patient who
is under a certain age and now it's
every,
every day.
Basically.
It's a stunning statistic.
It's disgusting.
It's sad to see,
and it's,
it's,
uh,
you know,
people are prisoner of their diet and
that's most of it.
And you know,
exercise plays a factor for sure it
speeds up your metabolism,
but the bottom line is you've got to
stop eating shit and you got to stop
eating so much.
But it's so satisfying to people,
especially people that feel,
they just feel unsatisfied and
unfulfilled and unhappy and they're
medicating themselves with food because
they get this little charge every time
they stuffed a cake down their mouth or
they eat a sandwich or they eat a giant
bowl of unhealthy stuff.
I feel like you're going to break out
into being Kevin Spacey in the movie
seven where he goes out killing people
who wrote the law governing the way
you're speaking with such a disdain
because it's not.
It's not necessary,
right?
This is a disease that you're giving
yourself.
This is what's sad is like,
and I understand if you don't have an
education on this and some people don't,
but that's not the case with most
people.
Most people understand that what they're
eating is bad for them.
They do it anyway.
Well,
which shows you that it's not only about
you,
you don't do bad things simply because
you didn't know any better.
Right?
Yeah,
for sure.
It's exactly.
Well,
psychology is very.
Human.
Psychology is so unbelievably
complicated and that's why I love my
life.
That's why I love my profession.
Every day I wake up and I'm in a
playground,
what's the next problem that I'm going
to tackle and have fun studying?
That's why I love my life and I hope
everybody.
I often get people who write to me and
say,
what's the secret?
Why are you always smiling?
I'm always smiling.
Well,
number one,
I'm healthy.
I have a great family,
but I wake up every day excited about
the prospects,
whether they.
If you could find that half,
the battle's won.
Well,
you,
you're
position your life,
your,
your study is so.
It's so rich with information and it's
so illuminating in terms of like why
certain things occur in our culture,
why people do certain things,
like what's the motivation and,
and,
and your perspective on like knowing
all these motivations and knowing what's
causing all these different actions and
reactions.
I mean it's got to be just constantly
interesting because it is so much and I
get to meet guys like whew.
And hung out with guys like you are.
A great thing about my job is I get to
meet guys like you and learn all this
cool shit.
Thank you buddy.
Listen,
tell everybody about your show.
It's on youtube.
The sad truth.
Saturate s a d truth.
You could follow me on twitter at g a,
D,
s a,
a d and also I've got a public facebook
page.
Write me emails.
Say Hello.
Good to see my brother.
Next time I see you going to be a
fucking lethal weapon.
Indeed.
Thirty pounds less.
Bye everybody.
See you soon.
Cheers.